.
Thank you.
We're on definition of a child with a disability for purposes of special education.
The prime sponsor of that bill is whom?
Representative, are you here?
Yes, you're welcome.
So let's call you up and get marching on the bill.
Do we have all the green cards in?
Green cards.
Wake up, Rick.
Maybe green ought let's go instead of red.
Yeah, the department is here for technical assistance.
Okay, so, okay.
Representative Boyd, welcome.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
And through you to my esteemed colleagues of the general court, my name is Bill Boyd, and I represent Hillsborough District 21 in Merrimack.
And I come before you today asking for an ought to pass recommendation on House Bill 1513, which modifies the definition of a child with a disability to include persons through 21 years of age.
This language change to RSA 186C colon 2 would codify the federal definition into state statute.
Current federal law 34 CFR 300.101 paragraph A states in brief that a, quote, free appropriate public education must be available to all children residing in the state between the ages of 3 and 21 inclusive including children with disabilities who have been suspended or expelled from school as provided for in 300.530 paragraph D as you can see in the proposed bill the minor language change made RSA 186 C colon to uses that federal language verbatim I'm very grateful to two of my Merrimack constituents, Attorney Bob Bevel and the Honorable Nancy Murphy, for bringing this issue to my attention.
I have brought along copies of their testimonies.
They've been emailed to the committee as well.
I do ask that they be entered into the public record, as these has, as I just said, have been submitted through the legislature's online portal both are parents of children with disabilities and both are actively engaged with this with this bill which has previously been been before this committee having been filed in 2020 is house bill 1558 I hope you'll take the opportunity to when evaluating 155858 and 1513, that you'll take the opportunity to review their comments in that context.
As some of you may know, 1558 passed the Education Committee by a 20-0 vote.
While I am a new legislator, yet somewhat familiar to the legislative process, I know it can be quite uncommon for bills to have a unanimous bipartisan support and committee.
The fact that this occurred two years ago speaks loudly to the appropriateness and the rationality of this bill.
Today, I'm hoping that behind me are some parents that believe that the New Hampshire Department of Education should follow the federal special education law and that children with disabilities should be entitled to the same level of access to public education services in our state regardless of the school district providing these services.
Currently there exists an inconsistency amongst New Hampshire school districts in the interpretation of both federal and state law.
Consequently, access to special education services in our public schools for 20 to 21-year-old students has become confusing and, in some cases, frustrating for parents and their children.
There are many compelling reasons why children with disabilities who are aging out need House Bill 1513.
In the testimony today and the testimony that you have received online, I am confident that you will hear many stories from those in support of House Bill 1513.
For me, there are two compelling and salient reasons.
One, equitable treatment.
By codifying federal law with state law, the definition of access to services across the state of New Hampshire would be consistent, and the varied interpretation of state statute by our school districts would be eliminated.
While each student's IEP would most certainly drive their access to services, the determination of when special education support services end for our special needs students would become clearer and finite in being in control of the parents and the people that are helping the parents with these children.
And two, continuum of care.
Diagnosis, rehabilitation, and maintenance are key components of the continuum that guide and monitor the child and his or her development with the special education IEP.
As the child approaches that age out phase, parents of special education students would be able to work closely with their IEP team to create a smooth transition from public school to adult life, while building a future framework for their child's adult years.
Being new to the world of special education, there's been a bit of a learning curve for me.
One of the things that I've learned is I know that special education rules in 2015 and 2016 process during my process of learning was emotional for many people involved with the process due to the ambiguity between federal and state law.
I certainly apologize for any redundancy.
However, I want to reiterate that I see this bill as a great opportunity to align federal and state law.
This bill will clarify the law, create guidance to special education administrators and teachers, and make consistent policies and best practices in special education.
As a quick aside, I have been made aware of a letter written by Attorney Gerald Zellin to the committee in opposition to House Bill 1513.
I also want to acknowledge Karen Rosenberg and Mike Skibby of the Disability Rights Center.
I did have an ex parte conversation with them regarding the usage of the word inclusive.
Merriam-Webster defines inclusive in three different ways.
One, covering or including everything.
Two, open to everyone, not limited to certain people.
and three, which is the term that that the federal law uses which is what i'm seeking to include in the law is including the stated limits and everything in between as in a program for children three to twenty one years of age inclusive meaning children ages three to twenty and the age of twenty one using the language suggested by attorney Zellin in his letter would create further ambiguity.
Using the language as proposed and what is utilized by the federal law is clear, simple, and unambiguous.
Ultimately, New Hampshire students would not be granted more services than what is mandated by federal law, but passing House Bill 1513 would ensure that they do not receive fewer.
When students with disabilities leave high school better prepared to navigate the world and engage in successful social and professional relationships, maybe transition to post-secondary education, employment, or independent living, we are setting them up for success in society.
8th House Bill 1513 has great bipartisan support, both publicly and legislatively, and I would urge my esteemed colleagues to vote favorably on House Bill 1530 and vote ought to pass.
And the one last thing that I would add as it relates to the bill itself and the analysis, it uses the language up to 21, which I feel is somewhat contradictory to the body of the bill.
And I would urge that if there is an opt to pass recommendation, that that analysis be addressed in your report as being extemporaneous to the language of the proposed law.
Thank you very much for your time, and I certainly would be very gracious to entertain any questions.
Thank you very much, Representative.
Are there any questions?
Yes, Representative Cordelli.
Yes, if you're not going to be testifying.
Thank you, Representative Boyd, for being here.
Maybe you know the answer to this, but when I was doing my research on the age question, it seemed to me that it was over half the states do align with the federal 21 inclusive language.
I don't remember the exact number, and I wish I had brought it with me, but one of the questions also in relation to that is when they turn 22, if it's in the middle of the school year, do they continue through the rest of the school year, or are their services ended at that point?
And it seemed to me that my recollection of the article I read is that there's a split in those states that do 21 inclusive and some states provide for the rest of the school years and some do not.
Do you have any information or maybe the department would be a better source for that answer?
I would defer to the Department of Education, but I would strongly suggest to you that you can go one of two ways.
You can stop services when that child turns 22 or if they're in the middle of the school year, allow that child to wrap up the year and be able to complete the school session with his or her peers.
I certainly think that's appropriate.
Thank you.
Thank you for the question.
Thank you very much.
Are there further questions?
Yes, Representative Litchfield.
Thank you.
Thank you for bringing this bill toward.
In our particular district, we do cover the children at age 21 so I just assumed everyone did my question to you is I noticed that it needs to be put into this would be effective within 60 days my thought process is so that the budgeting happens kind of 18 months in advance would would we want to consider possibly making this although I think it's important important that it be effective immediately I don't know what that would do to school budgets so thank you very much for the question being a former town counselor and being very familiar with the budgeting process at the local level I think your suggestion is appropriate I don't think we should be blindsiding communities with the new law.
That could dramatically impact budget discussions, depending whether you're an SB1 town or an SB2 town.
You want to make sure that it gets vetted and that the budgets get vetted appropriately amongst the voters.
So I think it's a salient point, and I would hope that the committee might address that so that we're giving our municipalities the opportunity to, should the law be passed and signed into law, be given opportunity to prepare for that thank you for the question thank you very much further representative mullin thank you mr.
chair and thank you representative boyd i'm over here on the other side of the speaker good to see representative mullin yes thank you you as well um as you know this bill is near and dear to me House Bill 1558 was Representative Murphy's bill, and I was a co-sponsor on that.
Thank you.
The last time that we dealt with this issue, one of the concerns that some of the school personnel had was about this aspect of the end of the school year versus the actual birth date.
I mean, we heard arguments about pushing it out a year isn't going to accomplish anything.
It's going to be another disrupted school year either way.
And we also heard a lot about school districts, some school districts, allowing students to stay in school until the end of the year in which they turn 21.
Would you object to that being taken into consideration as opposed to going to the age of 22?
No, I wouldn't object.
I think it's important that we recognize for children with disabilities, and I alluded to this previously as it relates to addressing Representative Litchfield's question, I think it's important that we give municipalities the flexibility to be able to design how that student is going to wrap up their curriculum career at the high school level.
So I think while that's something I had not contemplated, sitting here and listening to this for the first time, it certainly is not an unreasonable thing to consider if it's the desire of the Education Committee to address the issue, but add further language in there to clarify and, again, to use the word flexibility to give municipalities the flexibility to be able to plan and prepare for it.
Thank you.
Are there further questions?
Not seeing any hands.
Thank you very much.
Mr.
Chairman, thank you and to the committee for your time.
I appreciate it.
Thank you.
The next person to be called is Chris Biso, and I am here as a member of the NHA-SEA Legislative Committee, which is the New Hampshire Association of Special Education Administrators.
I also serve as a special education director for the Mascoma Valley Regional School District.
I previously served in this capacity as well for the claremont school district i am here in in opposition of h bill 1513 as it's currently proposed and i think listening to um um the the gentleman previously here i think that we're all in agreement that I really the spirit of the law I think we all want more services for kids I think we all want what's best for kids and as Representative Litchfield brought up, sort of the main barrier at this point is sort of cleaning up some of the language and and and at this time if this goes into effect what the impact will be directly on school districts across the state in terms of the current budget cycle that we're that we're in and school district budgets are created in the fall and they go through a process and then they get to the to the town vote in in early March that process has already happened for next year so if this if this bill goes into effect it will have for some districts it will have a a significant impact on unbudgeted items that we haven't considered yet.
So that's really sort of the other piece, I think, is as we work with kids and we get them ready for transition, there is a lot of groundwork that happens between the school district and area agencies.
And there's a cross-section of work that happens in getting those kids ready to sort of transition into adult life where area agencies take over.
So I think there should be, as we're looking at this, a better clarity as to sort of what that intersection is between when school districts are working with area agencies and how area agencies are actually budgeting for kiddos when they turn 21 and area agencies sort of take over that.
And I'm not an expert in area agencies and how their budgets work, but I would like there to be a little bit more clarity in terms of what that might look like, especially if the majority of services that are happening at the area agency level at that point are Medicaid-driven.
So I think that there should be a – if we look a little bit closer at that.
There are a couple of other things.
As we look at – we're not only talking about sort of kids who – if you look at the ramifications for kids who are in out-of-district placements, and if there's a huge significant impact on school budgets for next year for those kids who would ultimately stay in those out-of-district placements which can range anywhere from 350 to 500 thousand dollars per child and and then you're only you're only talking about those kids you're talking about kids who who are not in out-of-district placements, but who are still retained and educated in their local school, ages 18 to 21, and how to appropriately budget for them for the extra year.
There will be transportation costs.
There's OT, PT-related services, all of those things.
So, again, I think that we're all in agreement with the spirit of the law.
It's how we at least get out ahead of it so we have enough appropriate time to be able to budget for it and again those those budgeting things have already happened for 22 23 so um it would put some school district my particular school district i think we'd be able to figure it out we'd be okay i think i would only be impacted maybe by about a hundred thousand or so um some other school districts that i work very closely with several kids kids in out of district placements where it would well run them a significant amount of money because they didn't have enough leeway to be able to better prepare for this um i can leave my testimony you know i had a written statement but i just really wanted to come and just kind of speak from the heart of how this will – we all want more services for kids.
There's no doubt about it.
But I think I'd like to see a little bit more preparation so districts are well prepared to sort of be able to handle the budget impact on that.
And I'd be happy to take that.
Thank you very much for coming today.
I do have a question then.
Are you then thinking that it may be wise to put the effective date of this off for FY24, effective July 1, 2023?
I think, yes, I think so for sure.
Because, again, the budget season has already passed for all school districts.
Everything's been done.
Committees have voted on it.
It goes to town votes in March.
And so there's really not enough time to sort of unwind, if you will, to include that for...
Thank you.
Are there other questions from the committee here right now?
Representative Luno, did you have...
Sure.
Thank you very much, Mr.
Chair, and thank you very much, Chris, for taking my question.
Would the effective date also impact the state's appropriation for the special education grant?
It probably would, yes.
Yeah, for sure.
How specifically?
I would want a little bit more guidance from the New Hampshire Department of Education on that.
Yeah, for sure.
There's only a finite pool of money that is – and it would get further distributed after we start to include this group of kiddos in for another year.
And again, I think it's probably within our culture.
We've got enough money to sort of spread it around.
It's how it ultimately gets allocated and at what level and who is responsible.
So I don't want people to think that this is not about getting services for kids.
I think we're all in agreement that we want services for kids.
But things will be impacted, and probably in a negative way, if this goes into effect for this July 1st, without giving us a proper notification to be able to budget for such things.
So just a quick follow-up on that.
So pushing this to FY24, as the Chair has suggested, would also push the beginning of this policy into the next, the's next budget cycle which would then be able to consider the additional resources necessary within the special education grant which is formerly known as the catastrophic program and these are specifically for some of the student counts that you were referencing.
That is correct.
Okay.
Thank you very much.
Representative Mullen.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair, and thank you, Chris, for taking my question.
My question has to do with the budgeting process.
When you are budgeting for students that have a large amount of tuition money designated to them when you're budgeting can I assume or am I correct in assuming that you take into account the entire year's tuition or residential costs when you're budgeting let me let me clarify it for you okay so if a student is turning 21 Thank you.
So if a student is turning 21 in November, when you're budgeting for that upcoming school year, are you budgeting for that student until November or through that school year?
If they're in an out-of-district place, we are budgeting until November.
Okay.
So there would be, regardless of whether it's 21 or 22, you're budgeting to the birth date.
To the birth date.
Okay.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Representative Ford.
Morning, Mr.
Ford.
Got to remember that thing.
I wonder if the eligibility question might be resolved by redefining it to make the student eligible throughout the school year in which the student turns 21.
Therefore, the eligibility is clear.
It runs the whole school year.
And then you don't get into this question of money or whatever.
Thank you.
Therefore, the eligibility is clear.
It runs the whole school year.
And then you don't get into this question of money or whatever.
And it enforces the issue, I admit.
But is that a possible resolution?
Could be.
It would have further budget implications for school districts, for sure.
Sure.
But it would be written in there, right?
You're eligible throughout the year, so you don't exit until graduation day.
Again, that could have a significant impact on a school district's budget where they're currently budgeting to their birth date.
Again, when you look at an out-of-district placement, that is not a court-placed residential placement.
So if a school district is, let's say, footing the entire bill for that, where it's not a shared cost, it's not a 402 kid, the average cost these days for not a district placement if you can find one anywhere in this pandemic right now, is anywhere from $350 to half a million dollars per kid.
And so those budgets, when you're creating them, they are currently being budgeted for until their birthday, until they turn 21.
If you extend that out for the entire school year, somebody who turns, let's say, 22 now in October, you're budgeting for them for almost another year for them to be in an out-of-district placement too.
So I think there needs to be some language clarity around what that ultimately looks like and ultimately what kind of an impact that we'll have on a small community who for one or two kids who are in an out-of-district placement will have a significant impact on a small community.
Thank you.
Are there further questions?
I thank you for making the trip here today and providing us that insight.
We will call next from the Disability Rights Center.
We have Mike Skibbe and Karen Rosenberg is now stepping in in a transitional mode, so both will come forward together.
Thank you.
Here we go.
Good morning.
As Representative Ladd said, I'm Karen Rosenberg, new policy director at the Disability Rights Center.
I'm with Mike Skibbe, my soon-to-be predecessor, to testify in support of House Bill 1558.
Excuse me, 1513.
I've got the wrong one in front of me.
Thank you.
This is why I need him.
So, as Representative Boyle explained, this would be a change in our current law to extend eligibility for students with disabilities who are not able to obtain a diploma until throughout their 21st year, so until their 22nd birthday.
And as you've also heard, this would bring New Hampshire's law in line with federal requirements under the individuals with disabilities Education Act I've provided one of my handouts for you the third one is a summary of how how ideas law applies in New Hampshire which I hope you find helpful.
So as you are also aware, this committee unanimously passed a similar, actually identical, bill two years ago, or voted that it ought to pass.
And unfortunately, it didn't make it to the finish line.
And it's unfortunate because extending eligibility to comply with our federal requirement is really important to a significant but small number of students with significant disabilities who need these services in order to perhaps earn they need the extended services to perhaps earn a high school diploma and definitely to be able to achieve as much as they can to be independent, fully participating members of our community.
So, I mean, the kinds of cases that I've seen as a staff attorney at Disability Rights Center include kids getting kicked out of school before they've had an opportunity to really do things like job coaching and have employment internships and really get through programs that would help them to live more independently like cleaning and cooking some people who could really improve on their communication skills and that extra year can be very meaningful and to their success as adults when they are done with school.
And I think it was perhaps, I can't remember, maybe it was Representative Ladd or maybe Cordelli who asked about the schools, the states and what other state laws are.
I think it was Representative Cordelli.
So the answer is...
or maybe Cordelli who asked about the schools, the states, and what other state laws are.
I think it was you, Representative Cordelli.
So the answer to your question is that there are about 30 states that have already done this, and that includes states like Alaska.
Let's see if I can leave a little list here Hawaii, Arizona, Georgia, Louisiana North Carolina, Maine as far as the question about end of the school year and what that means some states have extended the eligibility to include the end of the school year in which a student turns 22.
Some have not.
Some have created sort of a permissive policy where states that want to make that an option for school districts can so that those students could stay in school through the end of the school year in which they're 22.
A couple states, interestingly, West Virginia and Michigan actually extended eligibility to ages 23 and 25, respectively.
I don't see us doing that anytime soon.
But the point is that extending eligibility to comport with our federal requirements would be extremely beneficial, but it also doesn't require students who have not earned their diplomas to stay in school until they turn 22 so for students who are really attached to the school building and the school culture they might it might be meaningful for them to graduate before they turn 22 to have that experience of graduation at the same time that other students graduate.
But what we see with a lot of older students who are not going to earn a high school diploma, these students are not necessarily as attached to the brick-and-mortar school.
Their programs are more in the community.
They are doing job shadowing and internships and learning how to go grocery shopping and navigate public transportation, those kinds of things.
So it's just not as meaningful to them necessarily to be in school through the end of the school year.
Doing what this bill says would provide an option for those students.
So if they really could benefit from extended occupational therapy and job coaching and all of those things, they'd be able to do it until they turn 22 if they're more attached to the school and it's more meaningful for them to graduate or exit school earlier they could do that it's not mandatory um there there is a cost here um but it's it's it's not huge when you consider that most students with disabilities will graduate with a regular high school diploma.
The overwhelming majority will, and they'll do it way before they turn 21.
There is special ed aid, formerly known as CAT aid, available to school districts when they have really high-cost placements that they're dealing with.
So that runs through the Department of Education when costs exceed three-and-a-half times the average cost of an education.
So that's available.
There's also Medicaid to schools funding that helps for students that are Medicaid-eligible for schools to defray the cost of services like physical therapy, occupational therapy, speech language services.
So for all these reasons, I really hope that the committee will vote ought to pass unanimously like it did before on this bill.
I'm happy to take any questions.
Thank you very much.
Are there questions from the committee?
Yes, one question.
Thank you.
Do you know what happens now without the 21 inclusive language at birth date 21?
Do most districts end services for that child when they turn 21, or is it a mix of ending or continuing services?
So I don't think that I have not done a scientific survey of this.
And unfortunately, people only call my office when they're unhappy, right?
No one wants to talk to a lawyer to say everything's going swimmingly.
So I, over the course of my 16 years or so representing students, have had a number of cases where students are going're going to be 21 and they're they're booted out and it doesn't matter if it's october april i think i had one recently who um his birthday was in either it was either may or the beginning of june um a couple weeks ahead of the end so my my survey is very unscientific but i would say it happens regularly thank thank you very much and we do have the department here uh and we can get that type of information because hhs start stepping in we have medicaid uh and of course that medicaid of schools is administered through hhs via well directly to the school so that's a question which we can ask a lawyer along with the DD wait list and all that so with that are there's no more questions we'll take the next person and that would be technical assistance from the Department of Education I know there have been several questions raised so could we have that assistance then we have one more testifier after that to start with could you just introduce your name thank you chairman my name is Rebecca Fredette I'm the state director of special education thank you very much Rebecca Rebecca could you just give a brief capsule what happens when the Thank you very much, Rebecca.
Rebecca, could you just give a brief capsule of what happens when the students do transition into life from school regarding maybe what you do with HHS to capture the services that are being provided within the school district and transition into the rest of their lives sure so transition can happen anytime from the age of 18 up to 21 at this point so there are students who will leave at the age of 18 they graduate with their class they move on with their class and but before that districts are working with area agencies to develop plans to develop procedures that would happen after the student graduates so that those things Thank you.
But before that, districts are working with area agencies to develop plans, to develop procedures that would happen after the student graduates so that those things are in place.
Having worked with DHHS, I know they have a – when they budget, they need an entire year to be able to budget for a student once they have exited the school system.
So our work has been, over the last two years, to work with DHHS and the districts to say, please work with these students and the area agencies a year ahead of time to get all of the things they're going to need when they leave in place.
So at any point between 18 and 21, those things are going on in the schools.
They should be going on.
Districts are meeting with area agencies.
Parents are meeting with area agencies.
They're making a transition plan.
they're developing services for transitioning out and then dhhs is starting to plan for them stepping into those services thank you and i have one more before i'll release to the committee um there's a fiscal note attached to this and i i assume that came from DOE the it says for the informational purposes department is provided that an approved private provider of special education ranges from 22 grand to 140 I'm just rounding the numbers up thousand dollars is that just the state money I know that when we're talking CAD aid, the total package can be, as we've heard earlier, $350,000 and higher, and a lot of smaller towns have seen that.
So are we just talking state money here and not locally appropriated dollars?
Right.
So those numbers are for our New Hampshire-approved special education, private providers of special education.
Currently, all of the New Hampshire programs have a tuition rate between those numbers that you just quoted, I believe, $22,000 and $140,000 per year.
However, if you have a student that goes out of state, those costs increase, and there are schools that go up into the $400,000 range.
In-state right now, we only go up to about $140,000 per year for a student in one of the private providers of special education.
So to follow up, is that the money which is on top of other words?
We pay our three-and-a-half times per student, and then we go into the 80% range and then 100% when you get 10 10 times are you talking about the total package of the state but excluding the dollars that are appropriated locally for their share up to that 10 times per average student cost so that so what the 22 to the 140 is the educational rate that we set for private providers aside from that when we do special education aid the district could come to us and say we are looking for the 140 000 that you that we paid for the student to go to one of these schools we're looking for the paraprofessional that we had to pay for to go to this school we're looking for the transportation we needed to provide the occupational therapy so.
So then you total that, and that's when we get into the three times and the ten times the amount that we're going to pay for special education aid.
So we would take all of those, and we would make sure that they're all qualifying costs, and then the district would pay their portion.
Then we would reimburse up to that 10%, and then we would pay the full bill after that.
So it's all of those costs kind of lumped together, and then we total it.
Yeah, it's a cumulative cost.
Thank you.
Questions from the committee?
Yes, Representative Ford.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
I'm wondering about the circumstance in which a family moves into a town, and they have several children, one of whom fits this category we're discussing now.
What happens when you haven't had all that lead time to hook up?
How do you handle the trouble?
Sometimes districts, there's a couple of ways that districts have handled that.
Some of them will adjust their budgets to pay for it through their local budgets.
Some of them will apply for special education aid.
And we will allow districts to write on their IDEA grants.
So each year we allot an amount from IDEA that we receive from the federal government.
And so on cases like that, we would allow them a one-time of writing on that grant to pay for that because they weren't able to budget for it.
So there are a couple of options that they have.
It still is an impact on the district because it wasn't something that they budgeted for, Thank you.
There is also, and I don't know the bill, the law, but there is a provision that they could also apply to the Department of Education for, I believe it's emergency funds.
It was in one of the bills we did last year, and I just can't remember the number of the bill, where they could apply to us for emergency funds, and if we have it available, we could also assist them that way.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
Thank you very much.
Are there further questions, technical type questions?
Not seeing any.
Thank you very much.
And I just did want to clarify one question someone had asked about the impact on special education aid.
There would be an impact on special education aid because currently we only provide special education aid up to 21.
So once a student has turned 21, any costs after that, because we're following state law.
So if the law were to change, we would then need to provide special education aid up to 22.
So in follow-up to that, so then changing the effective date of this legislation would better prepare you to put these costs in your operational request?
Yeah.
Thank you.
Mariah Ryan.
Good morning, Mr.
Chairman and fellow Education Committee members.
My name is Maura Ryan, and I'm a parent.
Originally, Darlene Cody Gildersleeve was supposed to come in and speak to this bill, but she's not feeling well, so I'm just going to make a couple of statements here.
Right now, the federal law is up to the 22nd birthday.
This is taught both by Wright's Law and the Parent Information Center.
When parents go and try to enforce their rights and get their child to stay in school to attain college and career-ready skills, they're denied by citations of the state law.
Once again, under the Supremacy Clause, if the federal law gives the greater benefit, that's the one that's supposed to be followed.
This was actually taken to the New England District Court, the federal court.
It was a Rhode Island court case in which Judge Leipzig said that we cannot have multiple states defining what public education, when public education should end, otherwise we will have to different interpretations of the law.
He reinforced the fact that school districts are supposed to retain students through their 22nd birthday.
That court case actually came out in 2018, and schools have known about this since 2018 because it was widely publicized.
Right now, any special education student who remains in school would still be eligible for IDEA funding, would still be eligible for Medicaid to schools.
Those things are based off their attendance in school.
The number of children also who stay in school past the age of 21 is less than 3% of the total of all IEP kids.
And it does have a financial impact.
However, it's less than a rounding error in a school district budget in some cases.
And in many cases, the cost of AstroTurf is higher than the cost of the child's education.
My personal opinion is that life is more important than AstroTurf, but not everybody feels that way.
It also affects the future of the student and the future of our state, because if kids are not college or career ready, and they're not ready to live independently, which is what the crux of IDEA is supposed to support, then they're not able to contribute in our society effectively.
They won't be paying taxes.
They won't be working.
They won't be doing much of anything because they don't have the skills yet.
And unless their parents can afford to pay for a private place for them to get that training, which most can't, you know, it's a problem.
In many cases, this comes down to what, you know, right now schools, they have ESSER funds coming in, they have ARP funds coming in.
20% of that is supposed to be designated for students with disabilities.
And yet, no plan is in place in a number of districts.
What it comes down to for school districts is risk management.
Can the parents sue us?
If they can't sue us, then we don't have to act act but I ask you to act because the federal law says it is through the 22nd birthday and those kids deserve to have the opportunity to have meaningful lives so I'm here to support this bill there are other parents who support this bill there are many children who've been denied staying through their 22nd birthday well not many but some who really needed the help so I am here to support and I would be willing to take any questions thank you very much are there questions for Mariah Ryan not seeing any hands thank you very much for coming today with that we have no more pink cards up here so I'm going to close this hearing and we will reopen the next hearing at 10 o'clock yes yep thank you Thank you.
They claim...
Thank you.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman and members of the committee.
I'm introducing this bill 1421 relative to lead in the school drinking water.
The prime sponsor is not here, so this is just done to start the roll.
Thank you.
Thank you, Chairman and members of the committee.
I'm Brandon Kernan.
I work for the Department of Environmental Services.
I'm the administrator of the Drinking Water and Groundwater Bureau, who right now administers the aspects of the Safe Drinking Water Act that require schools and child care facilities to test for lead.
I'm here today with a couple of colleagues from DES that actually manage the program day to day, Leon Atwell and Cindy Clevens, and as well as there's colleagues from Department of Education and Health and Human Services who are involved with schools and child care facilities.
We have questions, detailed questions on those things.
I did hand out a letter, and we submitted one electronically yesterday, and our letter just wants to make a few key points.
This bill would add provisions to Thank you.
This bill would add provisions to the Safe Drinking Water Act that would clarify some notification requirements to parents when child care facilities and schools have exceedances of standards for lead.
It also adds language to the existing statute that would have enforcement.
We provide enforcement capabilities.
Our letter just wants to provide the committee with some considerations as they look at this bill.
And the considerations that we offer in this letter have already been incorporated to a very similar bill in the Senate, Senate Bill 452.
So we were successful in working with the prime sponsor to put some changes to the initial proposal into that bill, but we were not able to connect with the prime sponsor for this bill to do the same.
So some of the considerations that we offer are, one, to change the statute that's referenced in the proposed language for enforcement.
Right now it's talking about polluting a water supply.
There's a more applicable reference that could be used that is typical of how we enforce the Safe Drinking Water Act that would provide finding authority for not falling through with the requirements statute.
I will say while that finding authority exists in statute, at the department we do enforcement.
We do a lot of outreach, a lot of letters of warning, deficiency, timeframes to comply.
Finding's a very rare event at the agency, but at the end it is a red line that we can use if someone's going to simply not comply.
That's one consideration.
Another is that we suggest the statute include language such as some spill 452 to require that the facilities submit the results des just not collect the samples but actually submit the results it would help us administer the provisions better having that requirement and also where a facility finds an exceedance of a of a of a lead standard and they mitigate that fixture to resolve the issue that they have to sample and provide results after they mitigate that fixture so we know that it works.
Another suggestion we provide in our letter is changing the timeframe that the three rounds of sampling has to occur.
The agency has in hand substantial grants from EPA for specifically addressing lead in schools and child care facilities.
At this time, the grant dollars have to be used by sometime in 2024.
It's possible that's going to change.
We originally were led to believe there's no additional funding coming down the pipeline from EPA, but we now know that there has been funding authorized in the infrastructure bill for additional sampling of school and child care facilities, but it hasn't been appropriated yet.
That would be in the regular federal budget, which is under continuing resolutions right now, but it looks like there will be money in the future.
So we do propose a time frame now based on the money we know we have that we can give the schools to help comply with the sampling requirements to pay for the sampling costs.
And it may be at some point in the future we could even tweak that if we get additional funding to give schools more time.
There is a fiscal note attached to the bill.
Obviously, there's a lot of effort to administer the requirements.
There's about 1,500 facilities that have to complete the sampling, and it's a fixture, it's just not their water source coming into the building.
Again, we have federal grants for a couple years that we'll be able to cover the position at DES to administer it.
After two years, as I just explained, we don't know if we'll have funding or not, but that might be cleared up later this year when the federal budget is presumably passed.
I'd be happy to answer any questions.
Thank you, Barry.
I have one question, and then we'll turn it over to the committee.
I've been a water commissioner up in Haverhill, and we've had notices from DES that we've had to clean it up every now and then, or we're dropping below a limit we should be.
A notification goes out to the community, all those on the line, that here's what you got in your water.
Now addressing our schools, and as a school administrator, I've been to districts where we have had water which is not at the level we wanted.
It was in another state, however.
I'm curious to know how does that occur?
How is it identified in this state?
Is it up to the local school?
Or is it contracted out with somebody that has the certification to do that?
And then how is the results of that communicated to all the parents and to the public in that school district's area?
So there's a couple situations.
If the school is a customer of a water system, like connected to a town water system, and the town water system has unacceptable results, the water system has to provide the school notices and extra copies of the notices to distribute to the community at the school.
And I've seen that in practice where it goes out to parents in newsletters or emails and to staff in their mailboxes.
If the school has its own standalone water system with its own well, that has to be operated by a certified operator.
And that could be somebody that district employs that sends away for the training and they pass the test.
Or they can contract that out to a certified operator, and that could be somebody that district employs that sends away for the training and they pass the test, or they can contract that out to a contract operator.
And if they have exceedances, they have to notify the people in the school that are drinking the water and also post it in an obvious place where you put notices about the water quality violation and steps that are being taken to mitigate it.
Thank you.
Questions from the committee representative mullin thank you mr chair and thank you for taking my question i'm looking at the added language at the end of the bill that indicates that penalties would be levied under rsa 485 17 for failure to comply with the testing.
And I'm looking at 485.17 where Section 1 talks about something being considered to be a misdemeanor if there's unintentional dumping of lead materials or whatever.
Section B is a Class B felony.
Is there someplace where, am I missing something, is there some place where penalties are spelled out, what the penalties would be for this?
One of our recommendations in our letter, the third paragraph, and I know I just handed it out to you, suggests swapping out that proposed reference with RSA 4558.
That's more applicable.
And that essentially gets you to fines if you fail to comply after several iterations of warning.
So we don't think that's an appropriate reference as proposed, but this change would be...
Terrific.
So this would need to be amended?
Yes, we would recommend that.
Okay.
Thank you very much.
Further question?
Representative Ford?
At one point in my life, I studied geology.
And I'm wondering when I read this bill and its specificity, given that that's laudable, there are other contaminants for which you check.
And I'm wondering if the language of this bill needs to be expanded in a way to cover all the contaminants.
You're exactly right.
There's several dozen contaminants that we regulate at DES for public water systems, and we regulate them at different points in the system.
Many contaminants are environmental contaminants.
They do not come from plumbing systems or the distribution system.
And in those cases, we can sample the water at the source, at the well.
When you come to lead, though, that can be a localized source of contamination, a plumbing system in the building or the fixture itself, such that you need to actually test every place someone could get drinking water.
So you're right, there are other contaminants, they are addressed, but it's at the source, and it's a lot more feasible than going to every fixture, and there's no reason to, because some contaminants just wouldn't emanate from the plumbing system.
Thank you.
Further questions for Representative Luno?
Thank you very much, Mr.
Chair.
Thank you for being with us this morning.
Could you just speak really briefly to the difference in harm or the degree of harm caused by lead versus, let's say, arsenic?
Wow, that's a tough one to pick because arsenic is quite toxic as well.
Right, and prevalent in New Hampshire.
Right.
Probably, I think both are serious concerns.
Long-term exposure to arsenic is more a concern than short-term.
The short-term exposure to lead can definitely adversely affect a child, and there's no safe level of lead.
And so it's really important.
And lead is more feasible to address down to very low levels than arsenic is as well.
And so, you know, our standard for arsenic in New Hampshire is lower than most of the nation, five parts per billion instead of ten, and that's because it's a real concern with kidney cancer and other cancers.
Lead is equally as big of a concern, and that's why we are on parallel paths.
So it's not a hierarchy really there.
We're treating each one appropriately.
But you did actually indicate short-term versus long-term exposure gradient being sort of a difference between lead and arsenic.
Yes, we regulate arsenic based on a long-term exposure concern, and lead certainly could have an impact with a high-level exposure in a short period of time.
Thank you.
Arsenic based on a long-term exposure concern and lead certainly could have an impact with a high level exposure in a short period of time.
Are there further questions?
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
And we have Nancy Vaughn from the American Heart Association.
Yes, thank you.
Good morning, everyone.
Nancy Vaughn, Government Relations Director for the American Heart Association.
I've signed in neutral to the bill, but what I wanted to do was maybe provide some food for thought regarding remediation of contaminants and school drinking water one of the policies that we do support around the country and in New Hampshire we do have a bill in the Senate for this are the installations of fixtures known as water bottle filling stations and predominantly we are behind those because of the fact that it encourages children to drink more water which of course we want to do lead can be one of those issues that makes that a problem for schools to be able to provide children with with adequate water supplies so it's really just kind of a consideration I don't know if it's something that is already figured into a remediation plan for lead, but these devices, these units can actually filter out lead particles as well as other contaminants in water.
So, again, just wanted to throw that out there as an idea of whether that could be something that helps with the remediation efforts should a school find that it has too much lead and other contaminants in their drinking water.
I'm happy to answer that question.
Representative Porter.
Yes.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair, and thank you for taking this question.
Actually, I think you answered it in part of your – I know in Hillsboro, the town I represent, for years had a problem with lead in the drinking water.
At the elementary school, we had to run faucets before the kids came and all that sort of thing.
Installing the water bottles, filling stations, I'm sure it's still there, it must be still there, because they haven't replaced the pipes.
So those filling stations would eliminate the lead in their water if it was in there.
I'm not a specialist or an expert in this area, and I don't know if it depends upon how much lead particles are in the drinking water, but it is something that definitely can filter out lead particles.
Thank you.
That's helpful.
Thank you for your question.
Thank you very much.
Are there further questions from the committee?
Not seeing any hints.
Thank you very much thank you all right is there any are there any folks out there that wanted to talk that haven't that we're at the bottom of these particular cards right now not seeing anybody thank you very much we will close this hearing Thank you.
the well and into the aquifer and we had the truckloads of water to the school I was going to say thank you I've got to get a hold of his communication to us this is it right here.
Thank you.
Chairman?
Mm-hmm.
1671, the attic received bill.
Yeah.
That's been...
Well, it was scheduled, and then that's gone, and we put it off because of Frank not writing around.
And the date yes Thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman and members of the Education Committee I my name for the record is Erica Leon and I represent Rockingham 6 which is dairy dairy is one of 10 sending schools to public academies in New Hampshire which is a large part of why this came to my attention so right right now, we have requirements for public academies for the chairperson of the trustees of an approved public academy to certify this financial report.
And we have penalties if it is not filed.
But in the beginning of this this paragraph it doesn't specifically say that approved public academies need to file this it was an oversight in the language and this is just a simple housekeeping measure as it stands the current law says a financial report for each city school district and chartered public school shall be filed following the summary of receipts and expenditures according to classifications and then it puts that responsibility this amendment simply adds approved public academies into that first line which clarifies several other statutes throughout the the school money section it also adds the chair person of the board of trustees of a chartered public school because currently chartered public schools are required to fill this information out, but they don't have anybody who is the one who needs to sign under penalties of perjury.
So I apologize that I didn't bring this to everybody's attention last year.
Last year we passed HB 442, which added the requirement that there's some penalties if these are not filed.
It would have been a lot easier.
It wouldn't have taken as much time, and then you would have had one fewer bill this year.
But hopefully this will be a nice and easy correction to the statutes to make sure that it's consistent and clear and it provides more transparency to the taxpayers.
One of the challenges we face in Derry and in other sending schools is that they tell us the price of a stripped-down Corolla with roll-down windows, but fortunately, that is not the education we get.
We get a much more robust education than just the very simple level that is priced out on that base education we have a tremendous number of special education students we have a tremendous number of great programs at Pinkerton and the same at the Co Brown and it would do a far better justice to our school board who needs to speak to the cost of Pinkerton and to our taxpayers to understand that yes, it might be $400 more expensive than Lendendary High School, but if we think that's worth it, and a lot of us do, that's good.
This simply brings transparency about where taxpayer money goes in order to pay for students' education.
I'm happy to take any questions.
Thank you.
Are there any questions?
Yes, Representative Luno.
Thank you very much, Mr.
Chair, and thank you very much, Representative Leon, for bringing this forward.
Is this report also known as the DOE 25?
Yes, it is.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
Are there further questions?
I just have one just to make sure it's not required.
We have approved academies that are not in this state which New Hampshire students are attending.
The way it's written right now, it says an approved academy.
St.
Johnsbury Academy is approved.
Is this applicable to them?
I can't see how it could be.
You know, they're not going to send a financial report to Concord, but to Mount Pillar, but it is an approved academy.
It says approved public academy.
I would be happy to bring an amendment or have you bring an amendment to specify the statute which defines a public academy in our laws.
It's clearly spelled out as the private institution which is contracted for these students.
And it's a very clear and tight definition.
So if that clarity would help this, I think that would be fantastic.
It may help satisfy some people at the other end.
I know when we've dealt with that before, we have, from this state, approximately $1.5 million annually goes over to that academy by way of tuition students.
And it's important that we still have the availability to our New Hampshire students up that way.
And we don't want to mess up the system.
Absolutely.
Would you like me to figure out that exact reference, write that down while the next person is testifying and then propose that?
What you could do, I don't know if it's necessary.
It might be something we ask first to our own department to find out.
I just don't want any confusion here.
If it is necessary, perhaps we can just have something written real quickly and it can be handed off to somebody in the committee.
That sounds fantastic.
I'll figure out the line.
And I've spoken with the Department of Education about this.
They believe that it looks to be required, but this clarification is something they support.
And I'll just make sure that we get it as specific as we can so that we aren't catching St.
Johnsbury Academy or any others in this.
I think right now the way it is, it's not going to be applicable to the academy up there, but there will be that fear.
When we're trying to clean things up, we should clean it up, so thank you.
Thank you very much.
Representative Luno.
Thanks again, Mr.
Chair, and thanks again for taking my question, but your discussion here opens up a couple of questions as well.
So in the case where a school district has contracted with a non-public school, is that school district required to complete a DOE 25?
The school district completes the DOE 25, which ends up including the students that are sent to other ones.
The Derry Cooperative School District is a K-8 school district, so they have their DOE 25 for the K-8.
They do not themselves educate any students in the 9-12.
They send students to special education placements, they send to next charter school, and they they send to pinkerton but because they do not have that information they they cannot and do not file for the 9 through 12s so follow up on on that specific with with dairy's contract with pinkerton for the 9 through 12.
so does that mean that the department does not receive data associated with the cost of education for dairy's student dairy's students in grades 9 through 12.
when you look on the department of education website that part says non-applicable and i have no information no information that is within the department standards i was on fiscal advisory committee, and we actually have a school board member here as well to speak.
But that simply is the price that we get from Pinkerton, so we can back it out, but we can't report it in any consistent format with the Department of Education.
And I guess a final, well, actually, are we going to hear from the department on this one?
Well, the – Yeah, I do have a technical question on that.
So just along the same lines as the Derry School District contracting with Pinkerton and not being able to complete a DOE 25 for students in grades 9 through 12, how would then a school district that contracts with a non-public school be able to complete a DOE 25 for the similar reasons?
That's a very good question.
As I've gone through, I haven't found other ones that list NA for the high school years school years right right so i'm i'd like to direct that that question to um to um this event so thanks thank you okay are there any further questions of uh represent leon thank you very much thank you yep uh next uh card we have is Lynn Perkins good morning to all of you and thank you for entertaining this amendment I haven't been engaged with the education committee in about the last three years I was the chairman of the dairy school board at the time and through all the pandemic issues and whatnot I think it's probably taken it off of my specific radar I serve on the high school committee with the dairy cooperative school board or the school district school board and this has become something that's really become significant in in our to deal with.
The significance of this bill has been that it's a contract requirement with Pinkerton as a sending district that they disclose and break down their budget in specificity.
It has been a rarity that Pinkerton has done this.
They've only it on two occasions and on one of the occasions they didn't make the information relevant or acceptable accessible to our school board or our district that was in 2003 and the reason that information became highlighted was because during an annual audit, it was insisted that that information from Pinkerton be released, and it was information specific to bond payments interests in principle on bond payments.
They released the information, but they released it directly to the auditors because they didn't want the public to see the information they released it directly the auditors because they didn't want the public to see the information it was released again in two thousand thirteen fourteen by the accountant uh...
in our district did receive that information it has not been released again this is a contract year for dairy we negotiate every five years with pinkerton Pinkerton to decide whether or not to continue our agreement with Pinkerton.
this has been a couple of things that have been asked a couple of questions are significant to this contract which we're asking for now but one of them is release of the bond payments principle outstanding balances of all their bonds so that we can see where our costs are going.
This is a private entity that has untapped access to public dollars.
And that's significant for dairy because we're finding that every year we are asking for information about long-range planning with Pinkerton.
Their costs and improvements continue to grow while the student population continues to diminish.
And when we are trying to do our own long-range planning, perhaps looking ahead at what's down the road, what we should be looking at for expenditures, we can't get that information either.
Specific to this bill would be that release of principal payments, interest payments on bonds, so that we can at least, if they're not going to give us a long-range plan, we can at least say, well, they've got this much money that they're going to have to be paying every year to justify their tuition costs to us but we can't even do that so in our contract year this year we are requiring that they give us that information to which point they are refusing to divulge those bond payments and interest on in principle on all their bonds I I think that the most part gives you an overview of why this is significant to dairy and also Chester, Auburn, Hampstead, and Hooksett.
All are faced with the same circumstances.
So I'm willing to take any questions.
I may have lost my track of what I wanted to say in specificity, but I'm willing to take questions if I can help.
Thank you very much, Mr.
Perkins.
Are there questions?
Yes, Representative Luno.
Sure.
Thanks very much, Mr.
Chair.
Thank you very much, Mr.
Perkins, for joining us this morning.
You were formerly with the board.
Currently am, yes.
I'm actually in my last, I have three scheduled meetings before re-elect.
Okay, all right, fantastic.
Well, thank you for your service.
Thank you.
Do you receive any financial reports from Pinkerton, such as 990s or anything like that?
I can't speak to the specific form.
I can give you an example of what it is that we do receive.
I can actually leave it with you if you'd like.
But it just basically runs down what their costs are, what the CT program is, passes, resource rooms, NECC programs, which are, you know, NECC is probably specific to us, but it's an autistic-related program that supports a district.
We have general administration operations and maintenance instruction, instructional costs.
But like I said, the one form that I'm looking at right now is from 2013-14, and it says costs of new facilities, and it says board expense, bond principal and interest, land and building improvements.
We don't receive that last category broken down in that regard.
So we have no idea what the actual amount of money is that they're having to borrow, and in fact charging back to the sending districts.
And it's been a frustration that all of the sending districts Thank you.
is that they're having to borrow and in fact charging back to the sending districts and it's been a frustration that all of the sending districts have expressed in some level that's in at different times great thank you very much thank you further questions not seeing any thank you very much thank you very much for entertaining this do we have any?
So that's it.
So we have no further cards on this, so we are going to close this.
Go ahead.
Oh, I thought you had done.
Yeah, that's fine.
Oh, okay.
You have additional.
Representative Fenton, or Representative Senator, no, Attorney Fenton.
Today you're going to go all the way up the ramp.
Governor next, that's right.
Oh my gosh.
Representative Mullen, you just slow down there.
So I will have to get back to you.
No, that's fine.
I've got just a couple more along the lines of maybe what a public academy like Pinkerton and Coe Brown does file.
So I think I'd be interested, maybe the committee would be interested in learning more about what financial forms public academies.
And I would go on to say non-public schools as well, certainly non-public schools that contract with school districts, what sort of financial reports they do need to file, both with the state and also with the Internal Revenue Service.
So why don't I type that up, and then you and I can talk during the break, and then we can get you that information.
I just want to make sure that I have the information, the content that you're looking for.
Great, great.
No, no, thanks.
And this is not an early bill, right?
It's not an early bill.
Yeah, so we've got a little bit of time to.
So are we talking here?
So my question is to the attorney, governor attorney.
You're going to get me in so much trouble.
We have tuition programs allow K-8s to tuition to various types of schools.
We before tuition to Kimball Union, a private school.
Is it your understanding that if we were to follow through on this request, we would be looking for everything that's on the DOE 25, that's assets, expenditures, and revenues?
That's my understanding of the bill, that it would make the DOE 25 equally applicable.
Thank you.
But that's a cursory understanding.
I don't have the bill in front of me.
So this would actually be good information, too.
So let's take KUA as an example.
Obviously, the number of students from public school districts probably is very small compared to the overall enrollment at KUA.
So would they be completing a DOE 25 form only with respect to the students from school districts under contract, or would they be completing it for their entire student body?
And I think that's important from New Hampshire's standpoint because we're interested in, obviously, the information about our students in public schools.
Right.
I can understand the committee's question there.
So, again, why don't I work on crafting that and then I can touch base during the break and get that information to the committee thank you fantastic thanks thank you are the further questions of attorney Fenton thank you very much thank you with that I'm going to close this hearing.
Ten minutes.
you know the the information you're giving to the, there is a closed date that's still going right now on submitting that list to us.
So what we've got to do is clarify that report and say, as of this time.
What was the numbers on this one?
Four in support, zero in opposition, zero in neutral.
I do have a question.
That's just the online registration, right?
Yes.
We have the blue sheets, too.
So, yeah, I'm just saying that we would need that plus that.
Yes.
In some committees, they read the blue sheets as well.
Just wondered whether you were giving me the total or a piece.
That's all.
Thank you.
I'm not too excited about going in and auditing Holderness Academy or Holderness School or Kimball Union.
We're going to screw a lot of people.
Thank you.
Anybody else has the information?
They claim that it has to educate a big goal as $15,000 a year.
And they claim that it's $5,000 a month than other schools.
But when you bring it in, it's about more than a month.
So if you're doing an out-of-stout comparison, sure, we have a way better school.
And that's a convincing argument.
But when you're misleading people about the price, then that sets the towns up with other issues, and the school districts have a lot of issues, and just the lack of transparency.
I really subsidize that.
My concern is important, especially because there's already accountability well yeah and so when they build a justification is lost but if they want to pay for it what was an explanation Pinkerton looks like a college if we weren't at a point of contraction of college yes very nice I didn't get involved Thank you.
If we weren't at a point of contraction of health.
Yes.
Very nice.
I didn't get involved until we had a fight.
I worked with the daughter of my husband.
I was in the last one.
.
Thank you.
students enrollment, kids they're sending to some fines, they're paying over $30,000.
You didn't use it right now.
You think they sent it to you?
Wow.
I think in two years, maybe now, but it's a 20 year contract.
We have the department review it.
Right now, unincorporated to elementary school.
They don't have elementary kids.
They haven't sent any elementary kids here before.
They want $25,000 for those two kids for elementary school.
That's like a better business than I realized.
Yeah, right.
I talked to people.
I wanted to start a charter school, but that's not getting those kinds of problems.
I have a non-adventure.
Next year, I'll talk to you.
I know that you remain versus shadow.
Thank you.
Yes.
Perfect.
And so we should be able to change from there.
And then the moment when I spoke with the HSO DA, I was just refining it a little bit.
So I'll give the reminders to you.
Thank you.
So the sponsors are from a bunch of different .
There was lots of support from all this .
Thank you very much.
Good to see you.
.
Thank you.
It's felt the best.
I could use sausage, bacon, pancakes, everything right about now.
Take out her?
Okay, we're ready to go ahead here with our next hearing for today, HB 1355, Requiring the scholarship organization to refer suspected cases of misuse of funds or fraud in the Education Freedom Account program to the Attorney General.
Welcome, Representative Luno.
Terrific.
Thank you very much, Mr.
Chair and members of the committee.
For the record, my name is Dave Luno, representing the people of Hopkinton and Concord.
House Bill 1355 is a straightforward bill, but it's a lot more than housekeeping.
It adds a word, it deletes a few words, but as we know, words matter.
Truth matters, and children matter, and taxpayers expect that we are making sure that their taxpayer dollars matter and are used as intended by state law.
There's no doubt that the Education Freedom Account program laid out in RSA 194F was contentious.
I didn't support it when we had it as part of House Bill 20.
In fact, thousands of people registered their objections, far outstripping those who registered support.
And following public budget hearings where no one spoke in support of the EFA program, not one, over hundreds who spoke in opposition, it was hastily baked into the state budget anyways.
So I'm here this morning not to repeal the program, at least not yet.
Thanks for your laughter, Representative Cordelli.
I'm here to make this program better than it is today, and I really do mean that.
I'm here to offer improvements to the EFA program for you to consider, and there will be more, but for right now, it's an improvement to address fraudulent use of EFA funds.
According to the DOE, the average EFA student is funded by the state to just about $5,000 every year.
It's not quite enough to cover private school tuition in most cases, at least not without other financial assistance.
And it's a good amount of money to help cover materials and other expenses for students and home schools.
And when the EFA money is spent on products and services as listed in the statute, things like tuition, textbooks, computers, and other education expenses, that's good.
But when the EFA money is used for other purposes, that's bad.
It's bad for the EFA student, it's bad for taxpayers who fund the EFA program, and it's bad for the reputation of the program itself.
And there's another word for it.
It's fraud.
And whether we believe it or not, it happens.
So who cares?
No harm, no foul.
Wrong.
Really wrong.
Fraud harms all of us.
Everyone is being taken advantage of.
But you know who feels it the most?
The kids.
The EFA students.
When the voucher money is not being spent on things listed in the statute, it could lead to real problems.
Current events are hard to put aside, but it could be possible for EFA students to be taken advantage of in order to fraudulently pay for things that would never have been considered under state law.
You can use your imagination, and it's easy to see how some expenses just have no positive contribution to a child's education or their well-being, may even cause harm.
Like I said, current events are hard to put aside, but some children are in environments where they might not encounter other adults and could be at risk.
We're all mandatory reporters, right?
What this simple bill does is make sure the private contractor, the scholarship organization that manages the EFA program, is responsible to students and taxpayers to make sure the EFA money is spent properly, and suspected cases of fraud are reported to the Attorney General for investigation.
Let's protect students and taxpayers and put some accountability on the shoulders of the scholarship organization to report suspected cases of fraud.
There's no teeth in the current law.
Let's change that and protect kids and taxpayers.
It makes sense, unless the potential for fraud is just so remote, just so infinitesimal, and that it's just not worth even considering the possibility of the harm it could cause.
But please think about these kids and your taxpaying constituents.
Thanks for your time.
I'd be happy to take questions.
Thank you very much.
Are there any questions?
Representative Cordelli.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman, and thank you for bringing this forward.
I agree with one word on it, anyway.
If you would believe, the May to a shall, I think, was an oversight in the Senate that I completely agree with.
And actually, we will be hearing another bill in a couple of weeks, I think it's 1678, that tries to address some of the items that have been raised or questioned by JLCAR.
And I believe that this is on the list for that bill to be corrected as well.
Not so much in agreement on removal of three words, the intentional and substantial.
would that open up the door for someone to call up and say, you know, I think that they spent this money on such and such?
And would that be required to be reported then to the Attorney General's office as a suspected fraud?
Thank you.
be required to be reported then to the Attorney General's office as a suspected fraud.
Let me just take a quick note.
So thank you very much, Representative Cordelli.
I think that's an excellent question.
I think some additional words that were taken out are the words that would put the scholarship organization in a position where they would need to investigate the fraud.
As long as they could interpret substantial and intentional at face value, then I think we've got some common ground on this.
Thank you.
Are there further questions, Representative Lakers?
Yes, I had wondered not only about that phrase, but if evidence of fraudulent uses of VFA funds is obtained, and you were talking about fraud being committed, you know, it would be if fraud was being committed.
So I'm wondering why you took that part out.
Thanks very much for the question.
I took that out because that's what the role of the Attorney General, the Department of Justice, would be to investigate and obtain the evidence.
Just as what I was suggesting to Representative Cordelli, if the scholarship organization can make a sort of like a prima facie determination of fraud, of substantial and intentional fraud, then I think that should be sufficient.
I think that could be sufficient.
We'll be right back.
determination of fraud, of substantial and intentional fraud, then I think that should be sufficient.
I think that could be sufficient to then invoke the shall be referred to the Attorney General for investigation.
Thank you.
Are there further questions?
Not seeing any.
Thank you very much.
Great.
Okay.
Where will we go?
We only had one card on that.
Mr.
Chair?
Could I have either Senator or Representative or Governor Fenton come and just answer a question for me, a legal question.
I hadn't gotten there yet.
Is there anybody else in the public that did not submit a red card or a pink card?
Okay.
Are you available for this from the department, attorney Fenton?
Thank you.
Welcome.
You have a question?
Yes, I actually have two.
One is intentional, substantial, sound like legal terms to me.
And I was wondering if they are and if there are specific guidelines to intentional and substantial.
I mean, it seems to me they're kind of objective terms.
And my other question is, kind of goes back to the appointment of a person at DOE to oversee the or to help administer the EFA program, whether that person would then also be able to report intentional substantial fraud as they might see it from their point of view, whether they'd be handling issues that might come up.
So thank you for the question.
I know that the term intentional can be a legal term of art.
You'll see that mostly in the criminal law, although I'm sure it's used in other contexts as well substantial I wouldn't use that as a legal term I think it's subjective as to your other question if I understand it correctly it's could could this person who's overseeing the program at DOE, the program administrator, could Representative Luno's bill be part of their administrative duties?
Is that, in essence, your question?
Would that be part and parcel of the role that person were to play so um it's my understanding i guess that uh the scholarship organization now has hired a third party group to issue debit cards type of situation is that right?
They have some way to distribute the money and then get the information back as to how it's being used.
And they would be in the ideal position to see if there was intentional or substantial abuse.
So I'm wondering if in the mind of the people that are proposing to have this person at the DOE, if that person would also be in a position where they might actually come across intentional and substantial abuse.
I think it's very possible that they could come across that in their work, but I don't think that's the vision of that particular position.
That position is done to help families and to help administer the program.
It's not necessarily to proactively identify fraud, but I think that that person could certainly, in that role, have the opportunity to identify that, and I would suspect that it would be handled appropriately throughout the channels at DOE, but I think it was clear in the testimony that that position is to be more of administrative.
I think it's very similar to what we've seen with the charter school administrator, and so as part of that role in administering the charter school grants the department has had the very rare opportunity but it has happened to identify misappropriation of funds but in large part that that position is to help administer it in a positive way and to help that program be successful would that would that person have to be named in this particular bill in order to be in a position to report it or would that be just um kind of common practice that that person would that position would be a reporting physician I think it could be added to the list of job details that that person covers if this legislative body felt that was appropriate to do or that could be left to rulemaking perhaps.
Okay, thank you.
Thank you.
Representative Mullen.
Attorney Fenton, if you wouldn't mind taking a seat.
I was so close.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
I thought you were a speaker, and that's why you're right.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair, and thank you, Attorney Fenton, for taking my question.
Back to the phrase intentional and substantial.
Is there a difference legally between and substantial and or substantial?
Because I'm looking at this and thinking that even a little bit of fraud is a problem, that it doesn't have to be substantial fraud.
So in that phrase, would it be possible, Would it hold some sort of legal merit to have intentional and slash or substantial I think by adding the and or makes it broader certainly and you've identified that yourself I think in terms of statutory language and how it's written to to do the and or, and this is just my own personal preference, I think it looks sloppy.
And I think in terms of writing statutes, I would, again, encourage not to use that shorthand.
But that's really just personal preference.
And I don't know, honestly, I think Jen, Jen, Jen, for my, sorry to call Jen out, but she's giving me a cross-eyed look.
But in terms of kind of these legal questions, I don't know, I might be stepping outside of my lane just a little bit working for the Department of Education.
So I would probably defer to your legislative committee researcher on that particular question.
Okay.
Thank you very much.
Are there any further questions of the department?
Now, I'm saying thank you very much.
Are there any other pink cards out there or requests?
For technical support, is there anybody who would like to address a technical question to the...
Technical support from the scholarship organization?
Okay, thank you.
Come on up.
Sorry about that.
Matt Southerton, Director of Policy and Compliance at the Children's Scholarship Fund.
I think you're dealing with a number of issues this morning.
We have the bill, but then we have the larger issue of misuse and fraud.
When we look at our policies and procedures regarding the global issue of potential fraud and misuse, we actually have to look at three different documents.
We have to look at the law.
We have to look at the administrative rules.
And we have to actually look at the state-approved contract.
So some of the issues that you're dealing with, particularly in this bill, have already been addressed within the state-approved contract, CSF must notify the department within five days if we make the determination of suspected intentional misuse or fraud.
So whether you decide that you want to change the law in ad shall, you know, we don't have a position on that.
I mean, personally, it seems reasonable to be.
Our contract would require us to notify the AG's office regardless, so that's what we would do if we made the determination of fraud or misuse.
Intentional misuse is actually defined within the administrative rules that the Department of Ed has issued.
It means, well, they define it for the purpose of this program as, it means knowingly and willfully for any amount of funds.
But then we have to look at the law, and it creates a threshold of $500 or more or a Class B felony.
So that's one consideration.
If we step back for a moment and we look at the program, we have a layered process to prevent fraud.
And this might be an occasion where we should actually come in and address the committee at a later time and discuss how the program works and the different layers of security that we have in place.
I think it would be important for the committee to understand that every single transaction that goes through the EFA is seen by human eyes, right?
So families don't receive this money.
It's not like they're given a check.
They're not given cash.
They can't make purchases on their own.
So every single expenditure is viewed by a trained staff person, program person at CSF to determine whether or not that expense is allowable.
And then routinely those orders are audited.
So that's another control that we have in place.
Regarding this bill specifically, I think that you might want to be careful because if you were to remove this language, if evidence of fraudulent use of EFA funds is obtained and the intentional and substantial, I just worry that you could open up families to potential abuse by bad actors.
I envision perhaps, you know, an ex-husband or an abusive spouse that has – they want to make some sort of accusation against the party.
And if we don't have the ability to do some sort of preliminary investigation to see if those charges have any sort of merit before we escalate that to the AG's office, I think that that could put those people in harm's way.
Thank you, and thank you for the information.
When you just said initial determination, I can't remember the exact words you used, but would that entail looking at the transactions for that account to try and match the transactions with the reported suspected fraud?
Exactly.
So every incident would be different, right?
So we already have the process in place where a parent can't even spend money without a human eyes on it to okay the transaction.
So our decision-making requires if we receive a complaint, the complaint is received, an incident report is taken, we collect as much information as possible, and then we would attempt to corroborate that information.
Now, if we're able to corroborate any of the information, we would then launch an official investigation where we would begin interviewing and we would do a deep dive into that person's account and we would freeze the account until we made a determination whether there – if there was suspected misuse or not.
And if we did, then we would escalate that to the AG's office and we would write a report and give them all the evidence.
Further questions?
Not seeing any further questions.
Thank you very much.
Oh, pardon me.
Can I mention one other thing in relation to this?
If it's a question of the department.
Okay, thank you.
So with that, we're going to close this hearing down.
And where are we?
We're at lunch.
Could I mention one thing in relation to the last discussion?
Well, you could, sure.
Because this is for the committee, yes.
Right, yes.
As you know, we have an EFA legislative oversight committee that Chairman Ladder and I are on.
And the next meeting will be in March.
And I believe it is planned that there will be a demonstration of the electronic system called Class Wallet at that meeting.
So, you know, we can confirm that with you and let you know the date and time for anyone who's interested.
Good information.
Okay, not seeing anything else.
So it's one o'clock, we start back up.
Go out and find some good food.
At this time, 47 support, one opposed, zero neutral.
Thank you.
47 support, one opposed, zero neutral.
Matt, we don't have your pink card up here, Matt.
Oh, you left it on the counter.
Okay.
Thank you.
that Thank you.
I think we're ready to start our afternoon fun-filled session.
And to begin the fun will be House Bill 1661, relative to regional career technical education agreements, and I'll recognize the prime sponsor, Representative Ladd.
Thank you very much, Representative Cordelli and members of the Education Committee.
I may be the prime sponsor, but there are many people that have been involved in putting this effort together, including the senators sitting behind me, and many of those folks which are working in the CareerTech centers.
I appreciate all the support that they've offered us over the last years, plural.
So what I'd like to do is try to take about two minutes here to just talk about the CTE program we have in the state and the importance of this program.
You all have a little copy of some materials which I left on everybody's desk.
It shows the CTE centers, regional CTE centers that we have in our state, which I think the number approximates, and I can be around 28, not in our state, but we have five that run down the Connecticut River on the Vermont side where our children go to, and then we have the remainder, the other 23 sprinkled throughout the state of New Hampshire.
I think it's important if you go to page two of the handout that I've given you, it lists all the career tech centers, but it's interesting to note if you look at it that we have career tech centers that just don't receive from one school district.
Obviously that's so, but you can see that some districts have as many as nine or so centers, regional centers have at least nine different school districts coming to them.
And if you look down through that list, it's about, what, three pages in length or two pages or so.
It really identifies all that.
And it's kind of interesting to see where students go.
You might even see that there are some school districts that are sending districts that send to several different centers.
Now, if you go to the third page, I'd like to just address what these centers do.
We used to call it vocational education.
It's no longer that.
It's no longer you make the bookends or the birdhouses.
You learn how to pound a nail.
We're way beyond that.
In fact, there's a lot of data out there showing that the students who come out of the CTE program come out with a very high level of achievement on our statewide assessments.
They also come out with skills that qualify them for our workforce, and that's what this state of New Hampshire needs.
Look at all the different clusters, the career clusters that are now offered at CTE centers.
I just put this together rapidly last night.
Agriculture and food and natural resources, architecture and construction, arts, AV, technology, communications, business management, administration, education and training, finance, government and public administration, health sciences, hospitality, human services, informational technology, law, public safety, corrections and security, manufacturing, marketing, science technology, engineering and mathematics, transportation, distribution, and logistics.
These are all elements that our society needs skilled people within.
But you go beyond the cluster, and if you look at one of those specific clusters, and see what is being taught, for example, where science, technology, engineering, and mathematics is a cluster.
Biotechnology, computer engineering technology, electrical, electronic, and communications technology, engineering design, engineering technology, and general engineering technology, and engineering.
Look at those in AV.
Theater.
Those are things that never occurred within our vocational program.
You get into some of the medical areas where you have pre-med being taught at the CTE centers now.
So the whole dynamic has changed.
It's changed to keep in line with what our workforce demands are and where we're going as a society.
And it also just points to the importance of what these CTE centers are doing for us right now.
The next several pages where you see a 17 of 104 and 18 of 104, I that on and I'm not going to go through it but we talked about education rule yesterday.
Education rule does speak to career technical education centers.
I won't go into that because you can read it.
Jumping and within the last year or two years we know we passed legislation where we put a committee together to look into tuition and transportation issues.
We accomplished some of that, but have a long road still to hoe.
We looked at transportation, and we know that the cost of transportation for all our students in the state to go to a CTE center approximates $2.7 million.
In reality, though, we reimburse them around $680,000.
dollars.
And so here we start, we're coming into some of the restrictions or roadblocks are there that are hindering these centers to really go farther with what they need to do.
One, transportation costs.
We recognize that some students are not going to a CTE simply because the descending district doesn't have that transportation money to do so.
We also know that the tuition costs are high.
And the tuition costs, but you get a good bang for your buck, but the tuition is also a restrictive, seeing that we know that what we're funding totally of $9 million a year isn't really slicing or dicing.
It's not cutting it.
So we've learned that.
But there's other things.
And this is what this bill now, where we are.
On the back side, I've shown this sheet here where we compare our students with Delaware students in high school.
And we know that Delaware has a high percentage of kids participating with the same basic number of kids and our is much much lower so this bill does some very important things and I'd like to go walk right through that bill now fairly quickly.
It creates what we call regional career and technical education agreements, where all the sending districts to a CTE center that receives sit down together, and they have this articulation agreement, which they're looking at, which governs how they're going to be working for the next four years.
And they have to send this to the commissioner for review and approval.
It addresses these issues like calendar.
Calendar and scheduling of days which we function in the regular school district are hard enough.
But just imagine if you're in a center and receiving from nine different districts with nine different calendars.
Everybody wanting to have a teacher in service day on a different day.
School days that are closed due to COVID or closed to snow, different snow days, and on and on the list goes.
So one of the issues within our RCTEA agreement that we had, if you look at the first page on line 14, we want calendar conformity.
We want an agreement on how close can we get these calendars aligned so that we don't have any more than X number of days, which are diverging from the days which we have to be at the center.
In the past, we've had school districts which have had days which might be a vacation day.
The kid in the receiving and the sending school district has vacation day, but the center is open.
So now that student's having to figure out how to get there.
Fortunately, many of the districts are providing that transportation to the center.
Now, that's a good working relationship.
Agreements shall minimize schedule conflicts to better support cte students with as many hours as possible to fulfill their program requirements we're looking at disruptions to get start and stop times we're looking at unscheduled school closures or events we're looking at daily class start and stop times there's issues with that we look at the kids which are going to the five centers across the river in Vermont and their CTE course program extends a half hour longer than it does in New Hampshire and so the kids go over there and you have to cut bait a little early to get back for the classes which are starting the other side other side of the river, or vice versa.
And it's very difficult for that student to be a part of that whole program.
That exists, too, when you have block scheduling here that's different than the scheduling at the receiving school.
What we're trying to do is look at all those days between Labor Day and the end of the school year.
How many days within that calendar from Labor Day to the end of the school year can be dissimilar days?
We know there's going to be some.
This bill says five.
We got that language from the state of Maine, which has been successful in moving that direction.
But that took them years.
They started on this process back in 2013.
Now what we want to do is have a similar process here in the state, but we recognize that five days after working with folks in Salem and Concord, up in the Lakes region, up in Conway, at the centers, we're hearing that's going to be a real steep road to climb.
So we have an amendment that we will be foot and forth.
It's coming from a unanimous agreement of the people on the tuition and transportation committee, because they were tasked with looking at tuition and transportation or anything other affecting CTE programs, at a wide open avenue to work on and the recommendation came out 10 days.
Okay so we put 10 days in that.
When CTE regions overlap or students attend programs in more than one CTE the provisions of this section shall apply to both regional centers.
So that's the alignment we're looking at.
Going further with this, some of the issues we have with tuition and transportation, this is on the bottom of page 1, on lines 29, 30, and 31.
The sending schools who wish to attend a CTE subject to attainment of prerequisites space availability within the program and appropriate qualifications under rsa 180 a 1e that colon 2 roman 8b that has to do with charter schools who's responsible responsible for providing the transportation for a charter school kid?
It is the district in which that charter school student is living, not where the charter school is located.
So the responsibility for tuition costs come from the sending district in which that student for the charter school is living.
Transportation, I addressed that there just at that point in time.
Now we're also looking at the issue of there are schools which are saying you will take this basic course that's necessary for graduation as spelt out in ed 306 you will take that at our school.
We have since allowed a child to a student to attend a CTE if they're in grades 10, 11, or 12.
Many of those basic courses offered in 9 and 10 are required for graduation.
You haven't gotten into a lot of the electives yet.
There are schools that are just firm in saying those basic courses will be taught in the sending school.
Even though, we had this conversation just the other day, even though the competencies may be embedded in a course either in culinary arts or in some other aspect of what you're doing in one of those other clusters at the CTE center.
How do we ensure that a child's not going to be held back in ascending school because they're having to make this decision that I have to be here for my one o'clock class in this basic English course or communications course or whatever the required course is, and I can't get involved in the programs that people in the back of me are providing with the directors and the staff at the CTE.
It puts them out of alignment with that program at the CTE center, and really it's making them make a choice as a young student.
Here's the avenue I'm going to drive in, even though I want to be over there learning biomedical issues, which are taught.
I saw that taught in one of the schools, too, down there.
I'm just flabbergasted by what's going on in our centers right now.
This opportunity can't be denied to a student because they have to get tied up in the school that they're coming from.
So what we're looking at in the basic part, the last page of this, is how can we avoid this occurrence from taking place so the student can get those competencies while they're at the CTE center.
This bill provides for that.
It may be provided either by approval of the local district and the sending district agreeing.
Some may be doing that now.
I'm not denying that, but we know that there's others that are not.
So the other approach is that the embedded competencies may be approved by the Department of Education or the State Board, and they would get credit for graduation.
However, that will be done in conjunction with what they are requiring for competencies at the local district.
If, in fact, the course at the CTE center is only offering three of the five competencies, the student will get partial credit for that graduation credit.
That doesn't mean they get the credit but they're three-fifths of the way there.
And so that has been built into this law as well.
On the last couple lines in this bill it reads the requirements for this regional technical education center agreements rcteas under statute this and statute that as inserted by this act shall not be implemented until rules of the department of education pursuant to rsa 188 e colon 1a roman 2 are adopted and effective that means that even though this bill might be signed at the date which we have there at july 1 2022 it means that the rules have to be in place before anything can go forward and we know the length that it takes for rules to be made at the department the state board and approved by jalkar so there is time for transition in this process so So with that, I won't go any farther.
I will open it up for questions, and I will try to answer them the best way I can.
If I can't, then I hope that we can have directors or Senator behind me just able to answer those.
I know Senator Waters has always been very capable in this area.
He's been very involved with CTE way before I got involved with it.
But right now, I absorb this as my aspiration is that I think this is probably one of our most important things we can do in education today, is get more kids into our CTE centers, into those skill programs, and try to facilitate their being ready for our careers and pathways.
The indicators in RSA 193E that we measure the delivery of an adequate education contain a number of indicators that are CTE oriented.
Thank you very much.
Thank you, Representative.
Are there questions from the committee?
Representative Luno.
Thank you very much, Mr.
Chair, and thank you very much, Representative Ladd and Senator Waters for working together to bring this forward.
Let's see.
Representative Vlad, you had mentioned that an amendment, I guess, is going to be forthcoming and that one of the areas that would be addressing is the calendar alignment instructional days?
That is correct.
And I'd like to add, too, that there are two sponsors on this amendment, and we're not talking about that now.
I'm just advising the committee that this has been developed, Ladd and Waters.
When we have it as a committee, we will have only representatives on that.
we can't have a senator's name on it but at this point in time Senators Waters is gladly asked that his name can be put on this simply because this has been a total bipartisan effort and it's coming out of the committees which for example represent Cornell is on the advisory counts is an effort that we'd like to see go forward.
What I would be asking is that we can get support from our committee and do an amendment that addresses what's here but show a lot of good, strong support.
So, Mike, thanks.
I'm glad to hear that, Rick.
I think that's an excellent way to proceed.
My question surrounds the amendment, particularly as it's focused on the instructional days.
And as you know from your work in public schools, and as many of us know from our work on school boards, calendar is like one of the most difficult things um and actually it was it was probably my least favorite thing to uh to uh work on uh when i served on a school board um so i was just wondering and going from initially landing at five and going to ten um what sort of considerations were done particularly as as the region going from initially landing at 5 and going to 10, what sort of considerations were done, particularly as the regional agreements become more complicated if more than one CTE center is involved?
I'd like to respond to that, if I may.
Yeah, thanks.
When we put this together, we had several directors went through and did this with all the schools which were within that regional CTEA, our CTEA.
And we'd see things like Pelham and Wyndham and what their schedules look like in terms of the center they go to.
And spreadsheets were made we saw all the non-conforming dates and it's it there's a there's a number of them and for example in the state of Maine they don't allow a teacher professional day or in-service day to be allowed as a non-conforming day what they advise is that you try and get all these in that area on the same day so that you can have teachers from one district to another crossing the lines so you can actually save some money and people receive that type of training.
But we have exceptions to this as well, which we wrote into the bill.
Initially, it was for extenuating and emergency purposes.
A waiver can be granted by the commissioner.
Then recognizing, and after discussion with the folks that are directing and understanding and managing these CTE centers, it came, and the bottom line is kind of important here in the amendment.
It says, if the commissioner determines that all schools within the RCTEA have plans and are reasonably working towards the implementation of an aligned calendar to ensure compliance with this paragraph, an annual waiver may be approved, but a waiver for this purpose shall not be extended beyond July 1, 2026.
There's four years here in which a waiver can be provided for this type of reasonable effort.
You're working together.
And we've heard they're already starting to do this.
But with four years, that's getting in line with the Carl Perkins money, which comes down.
And we talked about the Carl Perkins money.
There's $6 million that comes from the federal government, and that's how some of the grants have been just recently doled out to these centers, and roughly around $4 million goes to the individual centers.
That Carl Perkins has to be renewed every four years.
We're getting the schedules here within the RCTEA agreements aligned with the Carl Perkins sequence of grants, and that's why we're taking the four years down below too.
But an extenuating or an emergency waiver can be provided any time in the future due to the fact that, well, look at what we're in right now, COVID, the pandemic.
Look what's happening on horrible winters when we get awful weather and you have to take these days off.
So waivers can be provided for all kinds of issues.
And hopefully, and I believe we're granting those waivers right now for various things.
The commissioner does that.
And it's usually a healthy working relationship that that is accomplished.
So the last sentence there gives the flexibility.
if you're reasonably working towards this end and they are believe me they all want to get to this end I think we can do this and we can get there Maine had a similar issue and there were some waivers given but there's their their transition was hars ours.
They went right to the five days, and that wasn't easy.
But their instructional organization with their SADs versus our SAUs are a little bit different.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Any further questions?
Representative Boehm.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Thank you for taking the question.
In start, one of the problems with the days we learned wasn't it that the CTE may start before Labor Day and one of the sending schools after Labor Day.
So that was one of the issues, but wasn't it, though, that one of the schools that was starting after Labor Day still provided transportation to CTE before Labor Day?
We're aware, Representative Boehm, of that situation.
We're also aware that the governor had a task force looking at that and looking at the possibility of starting all our schools after Labor Day.
That did not fly well with local control, and I understand why.
But this is why you also see in this legislation where all those days prior to Labor Day, we're not starting this alignment until after Labor Day to the last day of school.
So we're avoiding that mess up.
And I will never get everybody on the same page as far as when school starts.
You know, athletic programs and relationships with abutting districts, it all comes into focus and play.
And I think it's wise to do as this bill is doing Labor Day through the last day.
We will align all but 10 days to make sure this thing works.
It's the first time we've ever had the opportunity to move forward.
We have had this issue hammering on us ever since I've been here on education.
That's 14 years.
It's time to make it happen.
Thank you.
Any further questions from the committee?
Representative Lakers.
This was something that just popped into my head, was to wonder, if a school isn't running buses because they're doing in-service days or whatever, the parents of the kids can still drive the – I mean, the kids can still go to the CTE if they have other transportation.
Is that true or not?
That is true.
And I will also say that most of the districts are making that effort to get them.
That part they're starting to work on.
There is reimbursement if you're traveling in your own personal vehicle, which can be approved by that district, and you get reimbursed at 25 cents a mile the tuition reimbursement for a school bus per child is 10 cents per mile that's kind of weak but that's what we reverse them at thank you very much see no further questions thank you representative lad And next I'll call on the other architect, Senator Waters.
Thank you, Representative Cordelli and members of the committee.
Awfully good to see you.
I'm Senator David Waters from District 4.
And I was trying to think, Mr.
Chairman, whether you and I are now, are we the mutton Jeff of career and technical education, maybe?
But we haven't worked at this a long time.
And I think the chairman gave a great presentation on CTEs and on the bill.
But I just want to make a few extra points here as well.
So there is quite a history here.
It's been about 10 years that I've been working on the CTE issues in the Senate, and we did set up an advisory council under Senate Bill 190.
And part of the reason for setting that up was identifying many of the issues here as well as getting more of a legislative focus on the development of the CTE program, which we all recognize is so important for workforce development and the aspirations of our students.
And, you know, even 10 years ago we identified some key issues.
We needed to work on the tuition and transportation funding, and I will say as an aside that Representative Umberger has had some really good ideas about this on the committee of the Representative Ladd set up last year.
Also, kind of key points on transportation and the alignment of calendars.
And then thirdly, another area is to make sure that students can get the credits that they need, both as embedded credits, a lot of work from the chairman on math credits in CTE classes being counted, and now trying to take that step forward.
And I think that the kind of principle here is that we really do believe that New Hampshire students have a right to the opportunity to career and technical education.
It's their aspiration.
It's their family's aspirations.
It's good for the workforce and the economic development of New Hampshire.
And I think we're making a lot of progress to do that.
I know there's been a lot of discussion about the calendar alignment, and the approach that we took was to look at these regional agreements.
They had existed previously just primarily for the issue of the renovation and construction of centers, and up until this point, they had just been used mostly for that purpose.
And we said, why not use that as a way of having agreements through that kind of regional organization so that we're not trying to do a top-heavy micromanagement of CTEs from the legislature or from the department, but to say, you know best, use these agreements to work out the things that are in these bills, in this bill.
And that's why the flexibility is so important, as Chairman Ladd has outlined.
We have an aspiration 10 days.
In the agreement, you can build in some flexibility, and that becomes part of the agreement, and that will be okay.
If even after that, there are some issues, then the commissioner can help you out with a waiver.
To me, in some ways, I think the most important parts of these bills have to do with the opportunity for enrolling in the programs and completing the programs.
And really starting at the bottom of the first page here, how it is that they can attain their prerequisites, how it is they can attain their credits, and how it is that they can get space in the program.
And then on the next page, page 2, line 6, shall be given access to career and technical education programs for instructional time for those programs.
If the instructional time is supposed to be a couple of hours and you can't get there a half an hour after or have to leave in a half an hour before it's done, you're going to fall behind.
Now, we're even looking into what if maybe Jeff Beer can talk about this.
I said, well, why don't we see if we can't get the buses to have Wi-Fi so that a student might be able to tune into the classroom and get some of the instruction that they might be missing while they're in transit.
However we do it, that's what students need because they have to get their certificate or their credentials.
If they're going to go into the automotive, they they've got to get they have to fulfill certain number of credits a certain number of hours there and then the heart of it of course is is in section 4 CTE credits and here the proficiencies competencies this principle if we put it in statute before and now we're saying we really mean it, you know.
You ought to recognize these competencies.
That's where the answer's on the lead on competency education and that kinds of flexibility.
And then also it says, look, you really do need to find a way for the sending school to give approval to what the education they're getting in the receiving school.
Because we've had some examples where there's a little possessiveness there.
Certain departments in the sending schools say, no, we want to make sure we keep our enrollments here on that.
And this says, no, no, let's be student-centered here, right?
Let's be student-centered and make sure it can work for the student.
So I just wanted to mention those things, but just to conclude by saying that this is just so important for workforce development.
I think that we all have seen what's been going on.
Our employers are just crying out, particularly in a lot of these technical fields, and we have done a lot on dual and concurrent enrollments.
You're going to see Bill from me a little bit later on in the session that makes sure the sophomores can participate in that and non-STEN students can participate in the dual and concurrent enrollment program and get tuition reimbursements as well.
This is just key for us to build the workforce of the future.
As I said before, I think it really is also the philosophy of New Hampshire.
We're an opportunity society.
We're student-centered.
We're family-centered.
We want these students to meet their aspirations and have their opportunities, and that's what CTEs can give them.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Thank you, Senator.
Any questions for the Senator from the committee?
Representative Luno.
Great.
Thank you very much, Mr.
Chair.
Thank you very much, Senator, for joining us this afternoon.
Just a couple of questions, particularly along the page 2, section 4 of the bill.
First question really goes to the embedded core competencies as approved, and I certainly understand it was approved by the sending district under the terms of the agreement, but what are you getting at here as approved by or by the State Board of Education?
well I think that there is a there is a by or by the State Board of Education?
Well, I think that there is a mechanism here whereby, through the review of these reasonable agreements, it may be that the State Board of Education has a role for approving these.
And so that's all.
I think Jeff Beard can speak a little bit more to that as to which programs and which courses that might kick in for.
Okay, that's right.
But the ideal here is for the RCTEA to cover that.
Right, right.
No, I'll save that question for a little bit later then.
And just a follow-up, Mr.
Chair.
The final sentence, I think, in Section 4 sort of relates to, I'd call it, unbundled competencies and getting partial credit.
And one of your comments, Senator, was that New Hampshire is in the lead, and I would assume in the lead nationally in terms of competency-based education.
And I'm just wondering how these unbundled competencies fit into, I guess, that sort of solid, rigorous commitment to competency-based ed.
Well, I would think here, and again, I think the chairman has some particular thoughts about this in terms of math and some other things, that certainly in some of the CTE courses that you would have a competency in a certain area of, say, math or the sciences, but certainly that CTE course as a whole would not provide all the credit for the required course from the sending school.
So it's a way of recognizing that.
And there are some partial credit courses at CTEs as well.
Okay, great.
Thanks.
So the way I'm understanding that is that they're not unbundled from the package of competency designed in the CTE course or program, but they just might not align 100% to a graduation requirement.
Right, you've got it.
You said it better than I was trying to.
Thank you very much.
Any further questions?
Representative Bohm.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Thank you for taking the question.
On the competencies, if the receiving school, the CTE center, which is in a school, for example, Salem, for example, they have a biomed course, which that school gives all the competencies needed for one of the science class.
If the CTE center has all those competencies, shouldn't the sending school also allow those competencies?
Well, I personally would think that makes a whole lot of sense.
What we thought was best is to let that be part of the RCTEA agreement so that there could be an acknowledgment from the sending school yeah we feel good about that and for this student's schedule there's no way they can do the CTE without having that happen and so I hope that that's what we will see that kind of cooperation thank you thank you seeing no further questions thank you very much senator for being here.
Thank you all.
Have a good afternoon, a good weekend.
Next we have Jen Haskins.
Good afternoon.
My name is Jennifer Haskins, and I am the president of NICTA, which is the New Hampshire Career and Technical Education Association, the statewide organization that supports career and technical education in New Hampshire.
Career and technical education serves about 9,000 students by their choice.
I'm offering oral testimony, but I've also passed around written testimony that I ask you to review.
I want to start by saying how much I appreciate the bipartisan support that this bill has given to CTE and for all the students in the state of New Hampshire.
We want to acknowledge and extend the gratitude of the lawmakers bringing the challenges faced by our CTE students Thank you.
students in the state of new hampshire we want to acknowledge and extend the gratitude of the lawmakers bringing the challenges faced by our cte students the nicta organization is offering this oral testimony in support of this bill the bill as a whole has an impact to impact cte in so many positive ways calendar alignment many students and centers have faced this as an obstacle for years.
And the intent of calendar alignment is what is best for New Hampshire CTE students to complete these courses and access their programs.
Based on the testimony that we've heard prior, I understand that an amendment is coming forth to increase the days from 5 to 10.
We strongly support that as well.
But one of the most impactful parts of this bill that I think we need to speak about is the embedded graduation credits within the CTE classes.
By stripping away this barrier that many students face when choosing a course for graduation in order to graduate and the ability to further their career path by attending a CTE program CTE centers for years have invested incredible time in curriculum design at the state and center level that we we try to remove these barriers, address the subject matters of both the CTE course competencies as well as core academics, while advancing these students in their career path.
Some of these examples can be found here in Concord at the Concord CTE Center and in Laconia at the Hewitt cte center where students that attend specific example the video programming program they have one of their sending schools gives the student the graduation requirement of half a credit of art and half a credit of digital literacy embedding those two into their program so that they are not asked to add those to their schedule each year the bill also evaluates the importance of cte and the role we play as a choice for students to have meaningful career opportunities within new hampshire and public education while ensuring that they also meet these core graduation requirements.
This bill has the potential to change the landscape and serve students and families in a far more progressive manner than we presently are.
As our full association reflected on House Bill 1661, we would like to have clarification by the legislative body in regards to the meaning and intent of parts of the bill that we specifically identified in our written testimony.
I'd like to close my testimony by highlighting for all of the committee members that though much of the focus and discussion has been on the alignment of calendars, It is necessary to keep in mind that the spirit of this bill is trying to remove the barriers for our students HV 1661 is about much more than calendar alignment it's about honoring New Hampshire students choices and removing as many barriers as possible for their success thank you thank you very you very much for your testimony.
Are there any questions from committee members?
Seeing none, thank you very much.
I believe there might be a couple of questions for Mr.
Beard from the department.
Is that correct?
If Mr.
Beard, if you'd like to testify, if we could also ask you to fill out a pink card, just say it's technical support, you can do that afterwards.
Thank you, Representative Cordelli.
Thank you, honorable members.
Yes, Mr.
Chair, thank you.
Representative Luneau.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
And I'm sorry, I was just reading Ms.
Haskins' points that she made with regards to clarity on some sections, so I may have a question to you on this as well.
But a question earlier to Senator Waters related to, let's see, no, it's actually line 22 on page 2, where a student completing an embedded career technical education course demonstrates proficiency in the embedded course competencies as approved by the State Board of Education.
I was wondering if you could sort of talk about what that means and maybe give us an example of what that is.
Absolutely, Representative.
I'm happy to.
So I just wanted to begin by making a distinction between CTE competencies and the competencies for embedded credit as listed in the bill.
Thank you.
So I just want to begin by making a distinction between CTE competencies and the competencies for embedded credit as listed in the bill.
When we talk about CTE competencies, there are a set of competencies that every CTE student must complete in order to show that they've completed the CTE program.
In the case here, we're talking about embedded course competencies.
So typically what we think of as academic course competencies, science, math, English language arts, things of that nature.
So an example could be a young person in a CT program who is taking a culinary arts course, they might have some course content that could demonstrate proficiency in math competencies.
They may not be sufficient to satisfy all of the competencies that would be needed to give them full credit for high school graduation.
but there could be an opportunity to identify the competencies that they're attaining that could give them partial credit towards high school graduation.
Okay, and a follow-up?
Yes.
So wouldn't those competencies already be identified in the CTE course that the student is taking as opposed to embedded course competencies that are, I guess, related to graduation requirements by the sending school?
That work would need to happen.
They would need to have that identification.
So at the present time, that is not often happening.
It is in some cases.
An example would be in the Salem Career Technical Education Center.
There is a computer science course that's also an AP science course.
It counts towards credit, graduation credit for the CTE piece, but also for the computer science requirement.
It's a graduation requirement.
So in terms of having embedded course competencies, that would have to be identified by the CTE center working in conjunction with the setting school.
Thank you.
course competencies that would have to be identified by the CTE center working in conjunction with the sending school.
Really, the sending schools have to accept competencies or course credit for graduation, so there needs to have that collaborative piece, which is what's spelled out in the bill.
Okay.
Follow up, I assume?
No, no.
You know, I've got to think on this a little bit more.
Okay.
So it may come back to me.
So thank you.
Further questions from the committee?
Representative Porter.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair, and thank you for taking my question.
I didn't get your name, though, sir.
Dr.
Jeff Beard.
I'm with the Department of Education.
I'm the Deputy State Commissioner for CTE.
Thank you, Dr.
Beard.
So I'm really new at this, dealing with competencies and how they work.
So say I'm a college, I mean a high school sophomore in the culinary program.
And part of that program requires me to double the recipe for a cake without using, you know, be able to do it in my head.
Which would obviously show that I can know how to deal with fractions, know how to deal with that kind of stuff.
If dealing with fractions is a competency requirement for a high school math class, then I, in my culinary arts class, showing that I can do that, have met that competency.
Is that what we're talking about here?
Yes.
Okay.
So what we need to do then is have an alignment between the competencies for culinary arts and my high school math class.
That's a big task, I would assume, to be able to get all the high school math teachers, all the high school courses competencies, all the culinary arts, and put them together.
Who does that work?
I'm so glad you asked that.
In the fiscal note that the department submitted, along with this bill, we put in under the section around the methods and calculations and methodology, we determined that it would take about half of the time, 50% of the time, of a full-time education consultant working within the Bureau of Career Development, which is the bureau in the department that oversees career technical education.
Some of this work would be specifically around identifying those alignments to say, these are the math competencies for high school math.
These are the competencies found in each career and technical education program and developing some model crosswalks that would allow the schools to then just plug in rather than having them do that work locally, which we acknowledge is a significant amount of time and effort.
Follow-up, yes.
Another question that I have concerning courses taken in our community colleges.
Are those sometimes part of the credits, the CTE programs, as well?
Yes.
There's a Running Start program that offers dual enrollment.
And that is something that all of our career technical education centers offer, running start courses that are also count towards graduation credit in many cases.
Sometimes it's elective.
And that's an important distinction also.
But it is a requirement for Perkins funding, which is the federal CTU funding, to include an opportunity to earn college credit while still in high school.
So many, if not all, of our programs do take advantage of that.
Follow up?
One more?
One more.
Thank you.
So I know that we have Chairman Ladd gave us facts and figures comparing the state of Delaware to the state of New Hampshire in their CTE program.
And I know because I have family and several grandchildren in Delaware who have gone through the school system there, and my husband has taught there.
So I'm a little familiar with that.
And I know that in Delaware, if a student's high school graduation grades, cumulative grade is above 3.0 or 2.5.
They get free tuition at the community colleges in the state.
All expenses paid for them.
And I'm wondering, in these programs that we have here at the CTE, Is there a charge to the students for taking the community college courses that are part of the program, or are those free?
I'm glad you asked that.
There was no charge to the student or their families.
The governor generously created a STEM scholarship some years back that's still in effect that's now been expanded to include all of the courses covered by Running Start.
Thank you so much, sir.
You're welcome.
Thank you.
Yes, Representative Tanner.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair, and thank you for taking my question.
I'm concerned about that area of embedded credits as well.
I'm a little confused by it.
And kind of going back to the contract that the sending school sets with the CTE, in that contract, is it kind of mediated out what embedded credits they will accept or not accept?
And also, I guess my second part of that is, if it can't be mediated out, is this statement or by the State Board of Education kind of the hammer that says you have to.
I'm glad you asked that, Representative Tanner.
So this is not yet something that happens.
So this would be new were this bill to pass.
But the idea would be that, yes, it would be mediated to be part of that regional agreement to have that statement of how embedded credits would be given for graduation credit.
And again, at this time, this is not happening.
But there could be an opportunity for the State Board of Education to make that determination.
May I have a follow-up on that?
Yes.
Thank you.
So let's say a young person wants to go into nursing, and they have the opportunity to go to a CTE and possibly get a LNA from that, but then they apply to college, and the colleges say, you know, you need to have a chemistry class, a lab chemistry class.
Can the CTE actually give a competency for chemistry that doesn't involve a lab?
Or how is that put on the transcript for me going from the sending school applying to UNH for nursing, for example?
To be honest, I'm not sure how that would work technically.
I would imagine that the way that they would handle that is, again, graduation credits determine if you have the content knowledge.
By earning those credits, that signals that you have that content knowledge.
So if UNH, say, requires a chemistry credit, then it would be the responsibility of the CTE center working with the sending school to determine how to ensure that young person has that chemistry credit.
And would the State Department of Education be involved in that?
The State Board of Education could be part of it, but not necessarily.
Thank you.
Any further questions?
Representative Luno got his question together.
Not really entirely, Mr.
Chair.
You know, there's a lot to like about this bill.
There's no question about that.
And Representative Ladd and I have talked about several parts of this bill.
I'm definitely on board with this, and I certainly recognize the importance of the work that Representative Ladd and Senator Waters and you have put in on this.
However, Section 4 is really what I'm sort of stumbling over right now.
And I've actually got, in trying to sort out what Section 4 means, I think I probably have half the sentences underlined at this point.
trying to and this could be a Friday after lunch type of, you know, fog, but I don't think so.
But, for example, for example, Dr.
Beard, just at line 17 on page 2, that begins, the rigor and number of graduation competencies and credits earned towards graduation shall align with the equivalent of the credits as outlined in the minimum standards for public school approval.
So that's in here.
Yes.
And as approved for the core course, and I'm not quite sure where that ties back to, by the sending district.
So the assumption is that the core course, whether it's a math course, a science course, et cetera, offered by the sending district aligns with the requirements that are outlined in the minimum standards for public school approval.
So there's that assumption.
Now, we know that the local requirement could go further than the minimum standards.
So it's really a yes-and proposition of saying, begin with the minimum standards.
Does the embedded course offering align with those standards so that you can determine that you can, in fact, award, say, chemistry credit for a cosmetology program?
In addition, does it align with the core requirements for credit in the sending school course if it goes beyond what's included in the minimum standards?
So a follow-up on that?
Yes.
So let's take the example that you just set out here, Dr.
Beard, where you're awarding a chemistry credit for a CTE cosmetology course.
Is that because the cosmetology course contains all of the competencies that is contained in the chemistry class?
For full credit, it would need to.
In other words, for it to be full credit, it would have to be the equivalent of what's being offered for full credit.
That is why there is a provision in this bill for partial credit.
And that was my earlier question.
Yes, exactly.
So in other words, if you could say of the, let's say, eight required competencies for science, this course satisfies three of them, then you could determine, and again, this is something that happens as part of negotiation, to say we'd be willing to give a partial credit, let's give a half credit out of a three credit course that the young person could earn.
And then through sort of a, I'm trying to think of the best way to word this, over the course of a two-year CTE program and then maybe an additional workplace learning opportunity, a young person could sort of cobble together all of the competencies required for a science course through the entire CTE experience, as opposed to taking one science course.
They could take a number of courses in CTE that include competencies that would be the equivalent of the credit for that science course.
Okay.
No, thanks for that explanation.
I think that helps.
I'm, you know, again, trying to get a better understanding, I guess, and maybe we don't have all of the resources to be able to understand that right here on a Friday afternoon.
But it sort of gets back to that unbundled competencies.
And if, let's say, my chemistry class requires me to understand, you know, requires me to demonstrate competency in five particular areas, what you're suggesting is that maybe one or two CT or more CTE courses could demonstrate competencies in, what did I say, five?
Thank you.
areas.
What you're suggesting is that maybe one or two CTE or more CTE courses could demonstrate competencies in, what did I say, five particular areas.
And, you know, I'm not an education expert, so I don't know if those competencies are better mastered together or can they be mastered in as robust a fashion through multiple courses or programs that are not bundled together?
Well, and I think the easiest way for me to explain it is that simply put, a competency is what somebody knows and is able to do.
So it has to be something that is demonstrable, something that can show evidence of proficiency.
So because of that, competencies don't necessarily build.
They're not necessarily sequential.
And there were times when somebody can demonstrate ability to a certain degree and then take some steps back and then need to build it up again.
So competency is something that is something that's revisited often, it's assessed often, and it's something that is better suited to a set of experiences as opposed to something that is more limited.
So in many ways, having the entire program might give more opportunities to attain competency and demonstrate proficiency than having, say, the semester-length class.
Okay, fair enough.
I mean, I think that's a good answer.
Thank you very much for that.
That's great.
I think I'm good for now.
Okay, thank you very much.
Any further questions?
Representative Porter?
Thank you very much for that.
That's great.
I think I'm good for now.
Okay.
Thank you very much.
Any further questions?
Representative Porter.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
I'm finding this very interesting.
So what happens if a course at a CTE includes three of the eight proficiencies?
What the other five, how does the student get to meet those?
if they're not part of the CTE program and he's not in the full course at his high school, where is he going to get those other five competencies from?
That's an excellent question.
There are a number of ways.
One of the beauties of education in the state of New Hampshire is that we do have a lot of opportunities and a lot of options.
So in addition to doing CTE programming, they could take a course at their high school, at the Sunning High School.
They could take a course through the virtual learning charter school, VLAX.
They could engage with a learn everywhere opportunity or do an extended learning opportunity.
So there's a number of ways that a young person could piece together the competencies for graduation credit and would not necessarily be constrained by a single course.
But it wouldn't be up to the sending school to provide an opportunity for that kid to meet those five competencies outside of the courses that they offer.
No, they would not have to.
Representative Tanner, possibly last question?
Okay, last question.
So to go back to my example before about the chemistry, so when I look at, for example, the handbook that my school has, the beginning of it has, you know, in order to graduate from our school, you need, you know, two credits of science, three credits of math, so many credits of English, and they're just listed as that.
So let's take somebody in cosmetology or maybe pre-nursing, that kind of thing.
And they obviously are not doing just chemistry or just, you know, I mean, they're working with chemicals or, you know, whatever, blood areas.
and so when the credit gets gets transferred back to the school when the school accepts the competencies is it recorded in the transcript is what I'm worried about So when the credit gets transferred back to the school, when the school accepts the competencies, is it recorded in the transcript?
What I'm worried about, I guess the underlying thing is, I'll tell you what I'm worried about, because to put it into a question seems like I'm unfolding, folding, and unfolding, is again that I'm worried that some of the students who go into CTE who then decide or who realize that they're going into CTE as a pathway to a college degree that they have to get to be in a profession.
And I know because I've had some students that were really interested in doing that and then applied to the college and had to go into general ed instead of the major that they wanted because they didn't have the courses on their transcript.
So when this comes through on their transcript, does it just say they've reached the competencies in science and it's not broken down by biology or physics or chemistry you know I guess that's my question it's a great question because of the nature of how the these local control the the term we always we always do every district would have a different transcript every district would have a different way of reporting that What I will share is that increasingly institutions of higher ed are more attuned to competency-based education and are more open to looking at what the young person can bring to their program.
They're always looking for fit.
So I think that that's something that, while it's a worthy concern, it's something that I think will resolve itself as this gets implemented.
Thank you very much.
Seeing no further questions, thank you, Dr.
Beard.
I don't see any other cards at this point.
Was there anyone else at present who wanted to testify?
Seeing none, I will close the hearing on House Bill 1661.
And we'll prepare for the next bill, which is House Bill 1283.
Thank you.
I'm all ready for you, Mr.
Chair.
Oh, I didn't, I'm not ready for the clerk.
I'm sorry.
Thank you.
the clerk.
I'm sorry.
I know.
Really.
Did I get the?
Absolutely.
Almost got really punched.
Long week.
Okay, we're ready to go ahead and continue our hearings for today.
Okay, 1283 is a bill relative to liability as taxable income of an education freedom account payments.
Okay, and we recognize Representative Luno, the prime sponsor of the bill.
Terrific.
Thank you very much, Mr.
Chair and members of the committee.
For the record, Dave Luno, representing the people of Huffington and Concord.
And you might recall earlier, but this morning I introduced a bill that would help prevent fraud in the Education Freedom Account program.
And there's a difference when it comes to fraudulent use of taxpayer money to buy a jet ski using the EFA dollars, like what happened in another state, and using taxpayer-funded education freedom counts in New Hampshire to pay for things that could lead to child abuse and neglect.
That was a lot more than housekeeping.
That was a very important bill.
I think this is an important bill as well, but unlike the earlier bill today, House Bill 1283 is really more about housekeeping.
It's really simple.
It repeals the one line in RSA 194 F2 Roman 6 that reads, quote, funds deposited in an EFA shall not constitute taxable income to the parent or the EFA student, end quote.
So, and obviously the way the bill is drafted, it has repeal language in there.
So repeal language typically does not show the language that's being repealed.
So that's what I just read to you, that 194 F colon 2 part, or Roman 6, funds upon the EFA shall not constitute taxable income to the parent or to the EFA student.
So let's pause on that for a second.
Is New Hampshire saying that EFA funds are not subject to federal tax?
I guess I don't really know.
So I think this is where the state of New Hampshire is in a position where we need to make things clear.
I'm not here to say that EFA payments are subject to federal tax or exempt from federal tax.
I'll say it again.
I'm not saying that EFA payments are not considered to be taxable income by the Internal Revenue Service.
In fact, I'm not even suggesting that the payments should or should not be taxable.
It's not up to me.
The Internal Revenue Service does actually run a web page titled, Do I Include My Scholarship, Fellowship, or Education Grant as Income on My Tax Return?
So you can actually find that page by probably searching on those words.
And it includes a tool to determine whether a scholarship deposit or distribution is taxable or not.
In any case, it's not our role to determine what is or isn't taxable under federal law.
And more to the point, we should not provide bad information in the event it is bad information to our constituents when it comes to federal tax liabilities.
That's clearly deceptive.
At the federal level, and this goes to actually the handout I passed around, and I'll reference it in a second, but at the federal level, Senator Ted Cruz of Texas has filed legislation in each of the past three sessions of Congress to amend the federal tax code to make education freedom accounts free of federal tax liability to the student or their family.
And you can see that if you go to page 9 of Senator Cruz's bill.
And on page 9, lines 16 through 22, it clearly states, not treated as income.
The amount of any such scholarship shall not be treated as income of the student or their parents for purposes of federal tax laws or for determining eligibility for any other federal program.
That's in the bill proposed and offered by Senator Cruz over the last three sessions of Congress.
The issue here, though, is the legislation hasn't been passed.
So what does this mean?
Well, good question.
Maybe it means that EFA payments are taxable under federal law.
Why else would Senator Cruz file the legislation?
But more substantive research into this hasn't really definitively indicated to me whether it is or isn't.
Tax law is really complicated.
So as an engineer, I can actually attest to that.
But I don't have an LLM in tax or the tax chops to get into the weeds of the federal tax code.
As a taxpayer, I know that some income is taxable.
I know that some expenses can be deducted from certain income.
For example, a 529 distribution used for tuition has no tax liability.
But a 529 distribution used to buy a laptop is subject to federal tax.
So what does it all mean?
I keep asking that question.
It means we should probably recommend this bill as ought to pass so that we're not providing misinformation and deceiving EFA families when it comes to the tax liability that may be incurred.
It's also come to my attention later, it was sort of middle of the day today, that the IRS does put out a publication.
I believe it's called 790.
And, of course, like many IRS publications, it's got a lot of pages to it.
And I did find terms right on the first, I think it was page five of that publication that defines what eligible educational services are and what is taxable and not subject to tax when it refers to scholarships for these education institutions.
And I think all of that is worthy of additional consideration.
but again what this bill does is not remove anything but does not change 194F in any material way that changes the program whatsoever.
And it does not change any EFA student or family's potential for tax liability or not when it comes to a distribution or deposit to the EFA.
All it does is take out a line that could be misleading to the public.
And I thank you very much, and I'm happy to take the question.
Thank you very much.
Are there any questions for Representative Luno?
Representative Cordelli.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Thank you very much.
Are there any questions for Representative Luno?
Representative Cordelli.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Thank you, Representative.
I believe there's half dozen, maybe seven states with existing EFA programs at this point.
Do you have any idea if any family receiving an education savings account or education freedom account has been taxed by the federal government?
So I've asked around on that.
That's a great question, Representative Cordelli, and thank you for bringing that up.
I've asked around, and it's really unclear as to whether anybody's even receiving 1099s on these education freedom accounts, as the term is used in New Hampshire law, and is actually used on Senator Cruz's bill.
It uses the term education freedom account.
So I think this is such a new area that the federal law has not caught up with it, whether either to clarify the tax liability status one way or the other, or to provide definitive guidance to students and their families, even when using the scholarship calculator tool.
But I think everybody at one time or another probably filled out some version of a personal income tax, and generally speaking, there's two parts to it.
There's the income part of it, and then there's the deductible part of it.
And so really there's a couple of questions that I think are important for our federal, for the Congress to identify here.
And the first piece is what is the taxability status of the payments that come through these scholarship accounts?
And then secondly, what is the deductibility status for use of those payments for certain expenses?
And like I mentioned, even on 529s, certain expenses are deductible.
Certain expenses are not tax deductible.
So I think it gets really complicated very, very quickly.
I apologize.
I should go back and get an LLM in tax.
But from the time I filed this bill until the time we're presenting it today, that was not going to happen.
You have a follow-up question?
Yes, thank you.
We have a little bit more time until the exec session.
I like these Friday afternoon.
You're supposed to come back and say, well, get used to it.
I hope not.
Sometimes to look at history is very instructive.
And actually, the Arizona ESA program is 10 years old, and there are several states that are five years old.
And would you believe that I talked with the vice president and legal counsel for EdChoice, and they know of no one in the country who has been taxed on their ESA program.
Yeah, I would believe that because I found it very difficult to actually get that information.
But at the same time, in talking with two tax experts in this state, they were not able to point to anything in the tax code that would support that tax-exempt conclusion.
Go ahead.
Would you believe that all of those state bills contain this exact same language about not being taxable?
I would very much believe it because I'm sure New Hampshire's language was somehow modeled on some of those states' language.
But again, none of those states are in the position where they establish federal tax code.
So I would simply say that until the Feds get this matter adjudicated, that they might also be misleading their constituents the same way we're doing that here in New Hampshire.
Any further questions, Representative Luno?
Yes, Representative Licas.
Thank you.
I'm curious.
This is the same state money that we send to traditional public schools, and the EFAs we're recognizing in the state as a school, a way of satisfying our 180 days, all that other stuff.
It's just there are now four different ways rather than three different ways where you can satisfy that.
And it's the same money.
So do the towns have to pay?
Are the individuals in the towns who are the students?
Because it's per student that it goes to the towns, are they also responsible for paying taxes, and how is this different than that?
The students on EFAs don't get money sent to them.
They mostly get reimbursements.
It's towards their education, et cetera.
I'm not sure why, since it's the same money going to a school in the state of New Hampshire, a way of doing school in the state of New Hampshire, why would one be taxed and not the other?
No, I think that's a great question.
And when I ask that question to people that do have an LLM in tax, I've gotten a very, very uniform, consistent response from these tax experts who say, no distributions from from the state directly to municipalities or to school districts are not taxable by the municipality or the school district as revenue going into those political subdivisions, no revenue going into those political subdivisions are subject to tax to be paid by those political subdivisions.
But in the case of an education freedom account, the payment's actually being directed at the determination of the EFA student or the EFA student's family.
So it's very different than the case of, let's say, an adequacy grant going from the state to a municipality or to a school district.
And it's the fact that it's directed at the discretion of the family that in fact makes it a taxable transaction.
Thank you.
Are there further questions?
Not seeing any.
Thank you very much.
Great.
Or me?
Oh, I didn't see Representative Porter.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
This is a would-you-believe question.
Thank you very much.
Great.
Or me?
Oh, I didn't see you.
Representative Porter?
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
This is a would you believe question.
My daughter attended graduate school.
I'm very proud of this, Cornell University.
And she had a National Science Foundation grant, which paid her tuition.
Every year she got this grant to live on, and that was totally taxable.
The grant that she got from the federal government, she had to pay taxes on.
So just to enlighten you, the group, a little bit, that was considered taxable income.
So thank you very much, and I guess what I'd like to do is go back and take a look at the IRS 790 publication and see where that is, because I'm sure that's laid out very clearly.
Okay, are there any further questions?
I did, but then I realized it was actually to Rep Porter that I wanted to ask the question and not Luno, and I can't do that now.
No, we can't do that.
So, no.
Thank you.
Great.
Thank you very much.
Thanks very much.
Are there any other folks who would like to testify on this bill?
Pink card in?
Okay.
Where's the pink card?
You know you have to do it for every bill, right?
Okay.
Thank you.
For the rest of the committee here, I think what we ought to do is put Representative Luno and Representative Cordelli in that room there, close doors, and you guys come out of there with resolution.
Okay.
It's Friday afternoon, but we do have one more.
Matt Southerton, you have the floor.
All right.
Thank you, Matt Southerton.
With the Children's Scholarship Fund, we'll try to make this brief.
I think that there's some confusion over federal grants.
Mr.
Chair, excuse me.
Could you move the mic?
I can't.
Yeah, sorry about that.
I think there's some confusion over federal grants and the EFA fund.
So the EFA fund was, the Education Freedom Account Fund was established to enable parents to use EFA grant funds for education related opportunities.
So it's very, very similar to a Pell Grant.
If you know what a federal Pell Grant is, a federal Pell Grant is tax-deductible as long as you use it for education-related expenses.
A federal Pell Grant also allows you to use it for non-educational related expenses.
However, those items or services that you purchase with those monies are taxable.
Unlike the federal Pell Grant, the EFA account does not allow you to purchase items or services that are not education related expenses.
So that is the difference.
Thus, it's not taxed.
Thank you very much.
Representative Porter.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair, and thank you for taking my question, sir.
So why does Senator Cruz have a bill in that will make it not be taxable?
Well, I could only speculate.
Well, please do.
I would assume that I could speculate, but I would assume that perhaps his bill wants to allow families to use or to purchase items that are not strictly educational.
Perhaps they want to use it for boarding or other items, which we wouldn't allow in this case.
Go ahead.
So while I have you here, this is a little off the topic.
I know that from what I've read in the press that the average grant is, EFA grant is somewhere around $4,700.
Correct.
Okay.
That's per student.
Correct.
Okay.
So if a family has five students, are they getting five times that grant?
It would depend because there are individual factors.
So the base aid is approximately $3,400 per pupil.
But then again, there are individual factors.
Does that family, do they qualify for free and reduce lunch?
Are they extremely poor and do they qualify for free and reduced lunch?
Are they extremely poor, and do they qualify for that so they would receive additional monies?
Let's see.
Do they have children with special needs?
They would qualify for additional money.
So right now, I can only give you that one base number, or not the base number, but the average number.
Follow-up So if it's $4,700 per child average, and a family has five children at their homeschooling, they're getting five EFA payments of $4,700 each for each child they're homeschooling?
If they are all in the EFA.
They're all qualified for the EFA.FA.
They're all set.
They don't have a whole bunch of special needs or anything.
All the kids are the same.
They're all homeschooled.
They're all getting the average payment.
They all get the $4,700.
If they're not special needs and they're not FRL, they would get around $3,400.
So they were all getting 5 times $3,700?
Correct.
Thank you.
Further questions?
Representative Litchfield.
Thank you for taking my question.
I just wanted to confirm, just in that example, if we're talking about the five children, and let's say they all qualify for the $3,700, if they were to attend to the public school in New Hampshire with that 3700 per child have gone directly to the public school so therefore either way we're spending the money to educate a child yeah exactly and you're saving you're saving a tremendous amount at the local level right right?
Because you're educating that student for less money.
Oh, exactly.
Thank you.
Are there further questions?
Thank you very much.
I don't think I didn't see anything else.
No.
Thank you.
Are there any other pink cards?
Not seeing any.
this hearing is closed.
Thank you.
I'll try and bring it in.
Are you starting right now?
Thank you.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
And I did pass in my pink card first thing this morning, so I wouldn't be embarrassed again.
For the record, my name is Marjorie Porter, and I represent Hillsborough District 1 and the good people of Antrim, Hillsborough, and Windsor, the Switzerland of New England.
Seriously, in our historical society, there is a plaque on the wall.
I think it must have been like the 1920s, but that's how it was advertised, because we had a lot of cross-country skiing in the area at that time.
First off, I want to make some things clear to this committee.
I am not anti-religious schools.
Children of Italian Catholic immigrants.
And in school, they experienced discrimination because of it.
They wanted us to be proud of our heritage.
And so they sent my sisters and me to Venarini Academy in Worcester, Mass., a parochial school run by an order of Italian nuns.
I could tell you some really good stories.
This must have been a real hardship for them, though, as they had lost everything that they owned as the result of a horrific tornado that swept through the region in 1953.
They had nothing left.
But it was important to them, so they made it work.
And I'm not against private schools either.
In fact, my husband and I owned and operated a private preschool and kindergarten for 12 years before retiring.
It was hardly profit-making as we kept our rates low to make it affordable, and we offered tuition assistance to those who needed it.
And I certainly understand the need for families to find an alternative to public schools to meet the needs of their children.
My own two children attended the same public school where I taught.
My daughter was fine with it, but not so my son.
He was experiencing difficulties, so we sent him to a local private school until he reached middle school age.
It was good that we had that option.
And finally, I am not a constitutional lawyer, or a lawyer of any type, for that matter.
When I mentioned that to the good people at OLS, they explained to me that in New Hampshire, the goal always has been to write our laws in such a way that ordinary people can understand them.
No need for a law degree.
All you needed was to be able to read.
That goes for the state constitution too, he said.
I can read and I have read the constitution.
I have filed this bill because I believe the use of locally raised property taxes to fund scholarships to religious schools is unconstitutional.
It needs to be made clear in our laws as well.
I have provided everyone copies of several pages of our state constitution.
The first two pages include part one, articles one through 11 of our Bill of Rights.
If you look at the dates of passage, you will see that most all of them were passed in 1784, when our Constitution was established.
Please look at the top of the second page.
Article 6, Morality and Piety.
I have underlined the relevant sentence and I have circled the date of passage.
Let me read it to you.
But no person shall ever be compelled to pay towards the support of the schools of any sect or denomination.
That prohibition has been in our Constitution since its very start.
If you turn to page three, you will see part two, article 83 of our Constitution.
It too has been there since the beginning, but it has been amended twice.
The first time was in 1877.
This is two years after James Blaine from Maine first proposed his infamous amendment.
This is our Blaine Amendment we have heard so much about.
It's been called the Anti-Catholic Amendment.
I agree this is not nice, but nonetheless it is still part of our Constitution.
Allow me to read it to you.
I'm sure I don't have the page.
Oh, here it is.
Provided, nevertheless, that no money raised by taxation shall ever be granted or applied for the use of the schools of institutions of any religious sect or denomination.
My husband and I have been retired for a while now.
We live on Social Security and a very small teacher pensions because neither one of us were fully vested.
Sometimes it is hard to come up with the money to pay our property taxes.
When we send our checks to the town twice a year, I know the town will take our money and use it for the police department, the fire department, the library, the roads, and the local community public schools.
In my town, there is a small Christian school.
It's been around for quite a while, and I'm sure the folks who run it are lovely people.
If you check out their website, you will see they are proud to tell us what curriculum they use.
It is a curriculum that advertises itself as a Christian curriculum.
It offers a religious education.
As I read the New Hampshire Constitution, it is not allowed for the town to use our money to fund a scholarship to pay the tuition to a Christian school.
The separation of church and state is one of the basic tenets of American democracy, as inviolable as part one, article 2A of the New Hampshire Constitution about the right to bear arms.
I hope you agree with me and look favorably on this bill, but I am not naive.
I hope you will think about what I have brought forward.
Think about it seriously and don't play word games.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Are there questions for Representative Porter?
Representative Cordelli.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Thank you, Representative.
We have had several bills directly and indirectly related to this topic.
And I'm wondering if you are familiar with the Espinoza Supreme Court decision, which basically invalidated Blaine amendments, and is wondering how you believe that impacts your legislation.
I am familiar.
I know about the Blaine amendments invalidation.
I don't quite understand why, but that does not invalidate our Bill of Rights.
It does not invalidate Article 6A.
Further questions?
Representative Likas?
My understanding in the finding is that if you have a program which is open to all schools but religious schools, like where the parents are choosing, particularly where the parents are choosing where the money goes, and they can choose everything but religious schools, that is religious discrimination, and that is why it's not allowed.
And that is why I find fault with a large part of the program that we put through this with a budget bill this year because it does not allow us to follow the New Hampshire constitution which says we cannot contribute our tax dollars to a religious school.
That's why I'm finding fault and that's why I brought forward this bill.
Recently there was a bill that we acted on that did use local taxes to pay for freedom accounts, local freedom accounts.
And I'm wondering how that's going to help the town of Hillsboro improve its science scores on the state test when the local Christian school uses a curriculum that says that dinosaurs and humans lived at the same time.
If my tax dollars are going to that kind of science education, and we're trying to raise our scores, it's self-defeating.
Thank you, and I'll talk to you one-on-one later.
Representative Boehm.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Thank you for taking the question.
Are you aware that the state law now also may require that you provide bus transportation to your religious school in your town?
I'm not aware of that, although I know when my son did go to the private school, it was on a bus line, so he was able to take a school bus to the school and home from the school because it wasn't any added costs.
I don't think that that's part of my issue here.
But it's taxes.
Further questions for Representative Tanner?
Thank you, Mr.
Chair, and thank you for taking my question.
Do you realize that, or are you aware that there are still court cases being brought in Maine and several other states challenging this separation of public money going to religious education?
I am aware there are other cases.
And I think the fact that Article VI in Part I of our Constitution was put in there in 1784.
That was 100 years before the Blaine Amendment.
It's the basic tenets of our Constitution.
Our democracy is founded on this separation of church and state.
And as much as it would have helped my parents to get tax dollars to send me to the religious school, it's against our basic tenets to use public money to pay for religious education, in my opinion.
Yes, go ahead.
Does this particular bill speak to a bill that hasn't been passed yet but currently proposed that would take at this point we're taking state public funds or people's business and tax write-offs to fund our EFAs.
But does this bill speak to a recent bill that was introduced that actually took the per-pupil cost that a local community, like you and your husband paying your property tax, that portion that goes to the school taxes, take out of that and actually take what it would cost, what you're giving to fund the school, the athletic programs, you water, the sewer, everything to that school building as well as the student that's over and above what the state pays to the education scholarship accounts?
Yes, I am aware of that bill.
It is a concern to me.
As I mentioned when we were addressing another bill when we were in Rep's Hall, my school struggles to meet its budget.
We have been living on default budgets for years now.
Our taxpayers are overburdened to pay for what we have.
And if those tax dollars are being used to fund separate other school systems more than what the town provides we're just going to be wiped out and I really concerned that it's going to cause deep cuts in our and our bill our ability to fund the basics that we are giving our students now again I, I get emotional about this.
I can't believe that we are actually allowing religious schools to be paid for with our public funds.
That goes so against all I've ever known about our democracy that I have a hard time even getting my mind around it.
And that's why I filed this bill.
Representative Luna.
Thank you very much, Mr.
Chair, and thank you very much, Representative Porter, for bringing this forward.
Do you feel that the state of New Hampshire could do a better job at directing state resources towards the Hillsborough Deering School District?
Of course they could.
I was looking at those Delaware numbers, and I was looking at the smaller size of Delaware and the huge difference in what the state is contributing toward the career and technical institutes in that state, and it was just eye-opening to me to see the difference.
What we could do with that money in our school is just amazing.
We have very dedicated teachers.
We have a difficult population to educate.
We need every penny that we have in order to do it as well as we can.
And a follow-up?
Yes.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair, and thanks for taking my question.
Do you believe, well, it's not a do you believe question.
How would you describe the Hillsborough – the resources that the Hillsborough Deering School District has access to in order to fulfill their obligation to provide an adequate – constitutionally adequate education to their students compared to, let's say, other school districts around the state.
I'm proud of our school.
We have a lot of good things that go on there.
We have excellent arts programs.
Many of our students have gone off to be music teachers and art teachers and artists and very successful in those areas.
Many of our students, like my daughter, went off to get doctoral degrees from Ivy League schools.
So I'm very proud of what we do with what we have.
But there are certainly a lot of programs and opportunities that our kids don't have that maybe the kids in Bow or Amherst or Hollis or some of those other wealthier districts do have.
And we do the best we can, but we certainly could use more.
I have a question for you.
Are you aware that during the last session, the statewide property taxes that you are asked to raise as a local was reduced by one-third?
I am aware that $100 million of education property tax, swept tax, was returned to the voters in the state.
And that $100 million is being taken from the Education Trust Fund to make up the difference.
Representative Likas.
Are you aware that that other bill we were talking about is enabling legislation and your town would have to vote to do that?
And it really wasn't designed for towns like yours.
It was more designed for towns who maybe just have elementary and decide that, or maybe it's too far for whatever school, for half the town or whatever.
It's for the town to decide this is what's best for us.
And I know my town, I don't expect them to ever vote for that.
And yours may be the same.
Perhaps you're not aware that in that same bill, if a town does make the decision to try it out and then decides it's not working, they are still liable to pay the same amount of money to each student that was originally enrolled in the program.
So if my town decides, yes, let's give this a try in 2010, excuse me, 2025, and they find out it's not working but 15 students have enrolled and we get rid of it in 2016 we need to keep paying those 16 students until they graduate from high school were you aware of that in that bill yes thank you are there further questions of the representative Representative Cord was.
Thank you.
Are there further questions of the representative?
Representative Cordelli?
Thank you.
I would just point out that the $100 million tax cut from the swept funds was made whole, so there was no loss to the education trust fund.
but my question is in relation to another one of our statutes that maybe you're not aware of is RSA 189 colon 49 child benefit services which allows a district to vote to send money to non-public schools for benefit services such as health services, textbooks, instructional materials, health services and that at least one town in this state votes every year to send approximately $40,000 to the local Catholic school in recognition that those children need some services, and they would be paying a lot more in taxes if those children attended the public school rather than the Catholic school.
Are you aware of that, Stacie?
Yes, I am aware of that.
Great.
Thank you.
And I'm also aware that in the $100 million of swept money, I also know that there are communities who collect more swept money than they need and keep it.
And I know that when the $100 million was approved, the cut, those towns were made whole.
So they would not be losing.
When that tax rate goes down, those wealthiest towns that get to keep the extra swept are still going to keep the same amount of swept money that they did before.
So again, it's a chance for the wealthiest, richest towns to get more money as opposed to the rest of us.
Okay, are there further questions?
Not seeing any.
Thank you very much.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Do we have any other cards on this particular bill?
Pardon me?
No?
So with that, we have no other cards, so I will call this hearing to close.
Okay, we will start the next one at 3.30.
Thank you for that.
Thank you.
Thank you very much, Mr.
Chair.
House Education, thank you for hearing me today.
For the record, my name is Sue Mullen, and I represent Hillsborough District 7, the town of Bedford.
Today I am introducing House Bill 1114, Representative Cornell's bill that establishes the requirement for scholarship organizations that manage education savings accounts to develop a directory of public profiles for education service providers.
This bill would require the scholarship organization to ensure that the education service provider directory that is on their website includes information about each provider to help families and students make the best decisions for themselves according to a recent federal government accountability office report nearly all voucher and ESA programs in the country include a directory of participating providers.
But a lack of central location for critical information, like accreditation status, services available for students with disabilities, school performance data, means that oftentimes families don't have the information they need to make informed decisions on their children's education.
In the report, multiple families describe challenges in getting information about whether a particular school could meet their child's needs.
Parents described attempts to enroll their student with disabilities in multiple schools before finding one that would admit their child I'm going to go ahead and get it.
their child's needs.
Parents described attempts to enroll their student with disabilities in multiple schools before finding one that would admit their child or that was the right fit for their child.
Several parents described the process of finding the right school for their children as trial and error.
Lack of information can result in parents discovering key information about a school only after enrolling the child.
For example, a family who has a student currently enrolled in a private school choice program said they wish that they had known that they would be charged for some of the special education services that that private school was providing to their child.
One family said they were surprised to learn that teachers providing education services to their child were not trained to provide those services, and another parent described changing schools because they learned aspects of their child's disability couldn't be accommodated only after their child was enrolled in the school.
A central repository of information on all participating providers would mean that families could have the information in one place enabling them to make the best educated decisions possible for the sake of families who are participating in the program i sincerely hope that our committee will find house bill 114 ought to pass.
Thank you.
Very much, Representative Mullen.
Are there any questions of the representative?
Yes, Representative Lakers.
Thank you.
Are you aware that some of these service providers only provide materials?
I mean, I love the idea of having some kind of, and I think we had talked about that as the thing was being set up, having that so parents could do that, but the way you've written it, it says every, you know, for each education service provider, and the service, the way, hang on, I'll get you the.
The definition of education service provider means a person or organization that receives payments from education freedom accounts to provide educational goods and services to EFA students.
So there are ones who just provide goods.
And so all of these things that you're saying they must provide doesn't even apply.
Yeah, I don't think that there would be a problem.
In my own mind, in talking with Representative Cornell, I'm a co-sponsor on this bill, I see a template being developed and then there being an option for not applicable to any section that doesn't fit the bill.
Sorry.
Or even if you are a provider having a place for parents to say, hey, this is a really inexpensive place to get whatever.
Right.
You know, whatever comments parents want to leave.
I just didn't want to see it try to go forward like this.
Yeah, no, I believe that that's why the but is not limited to is in the bill for the list, so that if the scholarship organization gets the request and there's a category not on the form, then they could add that to the form.
Right, but you wouldn't be able to have every service provider provide all of this information no no that's right but the name contact information the types of materials that they provide right yeah thank you you're welcome further questions perhaps mo and I have one for you.
Yes, sir.
Within the list of items here that the provider should provide, there's one called accreditation status.
Is there a purpose for limiting it to accreditation status?
We don't expect that from our public schools either.
There's also a narrative report that can be handed in in its stead.
Right.
No, I don't think it would be limited.
If it made more sense to have a drop-down box where you could put a narrative in, then I think that it can be explained easily.
Just so I explain, the narrative is an input-based, and there are certain issues or elements which are required within that, which should complement, if you're accredited, you don't have to do that narrative input.
Right, right.
And that certainly, you know, I would expect that this would go through rules like anything else and that the scholarship organization would have its own ideas about how to tailor this to the clientele.
Thank you.
Yes, Representative Moffitt.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Thank you, Representative, for taking my question.
I'm looking at this, and I see a lot of utility and value to this.
I'm wondering about if something like this were to move forward, maybe including sports or extracurricular activities, would there be a place for that, perhaps?
Yep, at the top one it says, but is not limited to, right before letter A, then yes, most definitely, I think, that if there were extracurricular activities, whether it be a theater program or sports or whatever, that a service provider would want to include that.
Thank you.
Representative Likas?
Yes, the other thing, thank you, that I had thought about was that some of the service providers are actually homeschool families who are selling their books, used books, to another family, and they have to be treated as a service provider, but they're not necessarily going to want their public information put out there as their phone number and that kind of stuff because they're just one family who says, yes, I have used school books, and another family is buying them.
So we have to be kind of sensitive to that as well.
Certainly.
Okay.
Thank you.
Representative Mullen, do you know if the scholarship organization is presently doing something such as this I do not I it could very well be something that was recently undertaken but because the program is so new we just sort of jumped on it and thought okay well let's look and see when other people were starting their programs what were the kinds of things that they felt they could improve upon and this was leading the list thank you are there any other questions for the representative not seen yeah yes Representative Cardelli?
Sorry for the late hand.
Thank you, Representative.
I'm just wondering, rather than the scholarship organization compiling a large directory, and I guess making it would have to be on their website, or I don't know if it could be a paper document.
It's not really specified, but wouldn't you think that a parent looking for an education option would possibly be already looking at options in the area that they live and have an idea of a service provider, whether it be a school or a theater company, as you mentioned before, and do their own investigation and talking to other parents.
There are all sorts of websites even for schools these days, niche.com, greatschools.com, and so forth, that have a lot of information information available don't you think a parent would be investigating on their own I would expect that a parent would be investigating on their own let me let me just restate again that this information came from the government accountability office which is the federal version sort of of our LBA if you will and that the info the quotes that I read for you came directly from their reports so this is a GAO report on scholarship on voucher programs so I I don't have a way to answer that question they collected the data and listed this as an area of weakness so I would assume this is representative Cornell I know that she took the the listed categories right from that report so they were just just trying to list helpful information.
Follow-up?
Thank you.
Would it be possible to get a copy of that GAO report or point us to the site?
If you look under Government Accountability Office, GAO, you'll find it.
I don't have the report myself.
I'm sure that Representative Cornell would be willing to look around for you, Representative, and see if she could get a paper copy.
But the Government Accountability Office has a full website.
Thank you.
Are there further?
Yes, Representative Lakers.
I'm wondering if you think it would be okay to – they already have to list all of the providers, which they do.
In fact, I just accessed it.
But rather than they all have to include these things, somehow making it so that they may include these things, just for reasons, like I said.
Some of them don't apply, and some of them are like a private family who is just selling textbooks.
Right, right.
And so is there some way to, you know, the idea of having information that, in particular, or have it open so that parents can make comments, you know, sort of like ratings or whatever would be great, but that's still do it as a may.
Representative, if you want to look at an amendment to this, I would be delighted to look at it with you.
Thank you very much.
You're quite welcome.
Representative Mullen, I have a further question on that list.
Recently we've heard from parents that they're trying to access and become familiar with the curriculum offered within a public school or school district.
Yes.
We're asking that in terms of the scholarship organization that they list and identify curriculum and teaching philosophy are all our public schools doing that well I think that's what we're trying to get them to do isn't it okay thank you thank you very much thank you are there further questions from the committee not seeing any thank you very much.
Thank you.
Are there further questions from the committee?
Not seeing any.
Thank you very much.
You're quite welcome.
Happy Friday afternoon.
You too.
We are not done yet, folks, because we have one more pink card here.
Matt Southerton from the Charter School Foundation.
Well, you are a charter school, so yeah, the foundation, yeah.
Technical support is what you've written down.
Thank you, Matt Southerton again from the Children's Scholarship Fund.
We just have a couple issues with this bill.
As a sort of data policy guy, compliance guy, I love more data.
I love collecting more so that we can see how we can prove the program.
One issue with this is that the amount and the types of data that you're proposing on collecting, I don't believe that even the Department of Education collects this data, and I don't believe that we actually have the legal authority to collect some of this data, so we would need guidance from you.
So, for example, school performance data, including test scores, retention rates, graduation rates, if applicable.
I don't believe that the Department of Education collects that from private schools.
So I don't know what would give us the legal authority to do that.
Now, in the EFA law, you do require us to collect aggregated data for the students that participate in the program on their test scores.
And that is one of three ways.
They can use nationally standardized test scores, the statewide assessment, or a reviewed portfolio by a certified teacher.
So that's one way to get at the information that you're looking for that we already do.
And they have to submit that once a year, or we can't give them the next disbursement of their funds to the account.
Another issue was the accreditation status.
I don't know how we would address that.
Curriculum and teaching philosophy, I think you brought that one up.
Also, total enrollment.
I don't know what would we do if a private school just refused to give us the data.
What legal authority would we have to request that?
So I'm perfectly willing to work with you all.
I think more information is good.
More information is good for parents.
I think that perhaps we can sort of narrow the focus and see what makes sense and see what's the best way to implement that.
But I'm open to any questions.
Are there any questions?
Yes.
Thank you very much, Mr.
Sharon.
Thank you for taking my question and hanging with us on a Friday afternoon.
Does your scholarship organization contract with these third-party ESPs?
With the who?
The education service providers.
That's how you refer to them, right?
Yeah, we do not contract with them, no.
They're not – follow up?
Not to my knowledge.
Yes.
Are they subject to any sort of scrutiny or approval by your organization?
Yes, absolutely.
Everyone has to be vetted.
They go through a whole approval process.
Every education service provider is vetted.
So take example, a private school, a New Hampshire private school.
A New Hampshire private school can only participate in the program if they are New Hampshire Department of Education certified, if they are registered with them.
Amazon.
Amazon has to go through the approval process.
We make sure that Amazon is an accredited business.
We check the Better Business Bureau, make sure that they don't have complaints against them for that.
Sole proprietors are a little bit more difficult.
What we do is we take those steps that I mentioned before, but in addition to that, we also go through the process of going through the national sexual abuse check and other procedures like that so that we can thoroughly vet them as much as possible.
And a follow-up on that?
Yes.
And I know I'm pressing everybody's patience here, but through that thorough vetting process, then, it's very clear that none of these service providers have an absolute right to do business with you.
That's up to your organization as to whether or not.
I would have to have the CFO discuss that with you.
You do business with that.
I'm going to defer to her.
Is she here?
She is not.
I could definitely put you in contact with those folks.
Then I guess what I'd like to ask you then is whether it would be possible as part of your vetting process and any other formal process that you have in place with your education service providers.
Obviously, you must be somehow transferring funds from a scholarship account to their account.
So there must be something on file, some formal confidential account number or something that you have to get from them.
Yeah, and I can definitely have them come in and discuss that with you.
So I guess the question is, could, as part of this very detailed, rigorous vetting process and even as minimal as the contract may be to include a remittance account number, that that could the answers to these A through J elements here also be part of that vetting and collection of data from the education service providers who are applying to be considered as part of your program.
That is a possibility.
I mean, I would have to get someone in here to talk about that with you.
To include that in the application.
That's what gives you the ability to ask for that.
They can say no, but also they're saying no to being part of your program.
Thank you.
Are there further questions?
Representative Porter?
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
As a parent of a child, and I'm looking for the best opportunity for my child, I think I would want to know if a service provider refused to give me some of the information that's included on this list, how many kids graduated, what their accreditation standards are, and that sort of thing, I certainly would hope that it would be noted then if the provider refused to give that information that it would say in the directory, provider refused information.
I mean, I think it's important, these things.
Parents thought these things were important.
It certainly seems like we ought to be providing it for them.
Yeah, we definitely have a process in place for reporting a provider if they have a complaint and for denying a provider eligibility to be part of the program.
And then they can appeal to the Board of Education if they feel that we basically kicked them out wrongly.
But if a parent had a child with special needs and they didn't find out until the child was already enrolled in the school that the school did not have a program to meet their child's needs, then that's a concern, because then the child is disrupted, has to go to another school, and that sort of thing.
I would think we would want to make sure that parents have that information before they enroll their child.
So I'm hoping that you can figure out a way to get this directory out there for parents.
Representative Cordelli, do you have a final question?
Yes.
With a child, excuse me, parent with a child with special needs, wouldn't you think that the parent would be talking to a prospective school in order to discuss their child's needs and the school's ability to provide those services in line with what's required in IDA for a parentally placed child in a private school?
Well, yeah, I mean not not that having that information is necessarily a bad thing.
But obviously, if I was a parent with a child with special needs, I would be doing my due diligence to see if that was the right placement for them, right?
And we do have parents with special needs students, and they're amazing.
They call me up, and they email me, and they ask us for help, and we help them, and we love it.
So yeah yeah, I mean, those parents are very active with their students, and I think they do their due diligence themselves.
But, again, having that information is not necessarily a bad thing.
Thank you.
Representative Tanner?
With as busy a schedule as people have and as chaotic as the pandemic has been, don't you think it would be a real, not nice is the word that came to mind, but I would like to have something a little bit better than that, make their lives easier, make parents' lives easier.
If there was a central place for them to go and just compare, look at this cursory to compare, because when I, for example, Thank you.
if there was a central place for them to go and just compare, look at this cursory to compare.
Because when I, for example, if I wanted to look for a school for my child and I could go down a list like this, say, oh, these three schools look like a good fit, and then go to their websites.
And a lot of their websites, private schools, have nice campus views and philosophy and their extracurricular sports and that sort of thing so that I narrow my search down.
Now, certainly in some areas of the state, you don't have a whole lot of options.
And so it may not be as beneficial to those people.
But certainly, you know, if you're in the southern part of the state or out on the seacoast area, you know, you have quite a few options.
And I just, do you think, don't you think that this would make it easier for parents and be something that they would welcome?
Well, I mean, I think this is all theoretical.
Again, I want to help parents.
I think we all want to help parents.
Whether they would actually use this data and whether, you know, they would put it to use, we just don't know.
And it might be something that we want to explore and say what would be the most beneficial data to parents.
What would we get the most bang for the bunk and we maybe want to want to bring some parents in and have a study committee on it and ask parents what are the things that you would like to know the most what would help you the most and bring them into this process ask them thank you are there any further questions not seeing any thank you very much and without any seeing any other pink cards this hearing is closed as a reminder for committee members uh next monday we have two subcommittee work sessions scheduled uh one at ten and one at one o'clock and then on the following Tuesday, Wednesday, Thursday we have more activity we are not here the next Friday if you would like me to schedule something on that Friday I will okay thank you very much and everybody have a good weekend.
Thank you.